e
good morning everyone it's 10:04 a.m. uh
we are opening up the meeting um and I
would like to ask representative Bel to
Al to the flag the United States of
America and to the Republic for which I
stand one nation under God indivisible
with liberty and justice for
all I want to remind everyone of our
mission we are a bipartisan committee
tasked with investigating and evaluating
the state's response to the covid-19
pandemic the committee will function in
a science-based fact-f finding review
specifically acquiring comprehensive
accurate data and all related
information pertaining there to areas of
particular Focus will include the
administration of federal guidance
acceptance of federal funds and
implementation of emergency use
authorization vaccination efforts a
report will be issued outlining the
committee's findings and the impact on
New Hampshire
um this morning we are supposed to have
uh uh someone coming in to testify and
we are missing some other committee
members but currently uh there is a
parade going on outside so I do believe
some of our people have been delayed but
I did not want to delay this hearing uh
for the public I think we uh the who is
the people that are here will'll uh have
a small discussion about we learned
yesterday um and uh
for me it
was transformational I I will say I had
no
idea that anything and I mean any
vaccine listed as a childhood vaccine
gets complete
immunity no damages ever can be filed um
from my understanding and if anyone else
got the a different impression um and as
it was stated there is no other product
out there that has immunity from
damages and our children are extremely
important uh represent
Belcher thank you madam chair and and to
further clarify that as
well
damages are capped um at a relatively
low amount but it's it's that damages
have to be
pursued against the government against a
government agency for any harm that was
incurred and the same government agency
that is tasked with
regulating and that is also tasked with
um as a
policy uh
promoting the um the vaccine so in terms
of a product you have you have the same
agency involved in in
promoting in
regulating and in defending the
government against any claims of Damages
because the uh the the manufacturers
themselves are immunized from any damage
which as we learned the the threat of
lawsuits and it's certainly true I think
that there have been times in this
nation where things have been a bit too
litigious but generally speaking the the
threat of financial um loss is is what
keeps businesses honest and it it is a
primary mechanism for um Market forces
to ensure things such as safety and
efficacy um thank you represent Bel I I
agree with that and and you know one of
the Striking things
is the government is supposed to
protect
us they're supposed to be our protectant
and yet in this case they are not they
are the
promoter um and they are the ones that
we the anyone filing damages actually
has to Sue I mean that is contrary to
everything else that we stand for um in
my opinion
because congressmen Senators legislators
we are the Servants of the people and
people need to be reminded of that that
they are in charge we are only here at
their pleasure and we serve at their
Penza yeah
um thank you um Madam chair and I just
um I just wanted to comment kind of what
you when you first said that because um
you that you weren't aware um I've been
very well aware for a long time in
regards with the 1986 act that uh
President Reagan had signed and um and
so I knew uh of the level of um immunity
that big Pharma had but I think the most
important thing that we have to talk
about here um from yesterday is all of
the information that was
given it was given to use traditional
vaccines to do a comparison like so we
could understand where we were at with
anything that had to do with covid and
and that it was so and there were times
where we stayed on that subject of
traditional for you know quite some time
to to really lay the groundwork for
where we were at with Co and in addition
to co it's more than just a blanket
immunity there were contracts that were
signed they protected by the prep act um
I knew all of that but to the
extent of those contracts and what was
signed um I didn't know to that and it
was
um it was that piece there in in
realizing
that
damages death suffering
injuries that no one when it comes to
covid um emergency youth authorization
injections they have absolutely no way
to get any sort of
compensation damages relief at all and
that was that's absolutely debilitating
to
hear represent
beler thank you madam chair and I
was I was repeatedly shocked by a number
of the things that we um we were told
and we saw
yesterday uh not the least of which
being um that in clinical trials for
miners for the MRNA I believe it was the
fizer
injection that a young woman who was
enrolled in the clinical trials
suffered what appeared to be
devastating um injury it is alleged to
have been because of the um
vaccine um but in any case it it does
appear that the corporation
involved failed to report that injury
that occurred in a clinical
trial um to the regulators and it it it
it really brings up a bigger question to
to me which
is why
are the clinical
trials being
run by the
companies themselves as opposed to some
sort of third
party yes well um speaking of that well
F uh two points um was that
the regulator the investigator said he
didn't
feel he didn't do it scientifically he
just didn't feel that it was
related well you know I didn't feel like
getting up this morning too early and so
I you know what if I just didn't feel
like coming
here I mean we don't feel when we're
dealing with science and we don't feel
when we're dealing with people's lives
facts the other thing is is when you
talk about
independent there is an independent
board but what we
learned is that one of the people on
that independent board was paid by
fizer and although she said well yeah I
was paid but I can still be
independent but there but then there
goes to bias you can't be independent of
somebody if you are involved in that
industry even you have to remove your
everything has to be removed for it to
be truly an independent
person there's all we all bring a bias
with
us you know every single person has a
bias but to be involved with the people
that you're
investigating goes beyond
and I'd like to speak to um
representative belcher's
beyond there really is no question I
mean after the injection it was almost
immediately what this this girl suffered
which was a client of the speaker and
but then our own government agencies
also
participated in non not having that
information come out so once they were
made aware still people didn't know
about it and I think that was really
really hard as well as he didn't get
into some of these details but I will
put in the record as well during
clinical
trials the um the deaths that
occurred uh most people didn't hear
about any of that information and there
is um I believe one person that has come
forward with uh their child that passed
and because of that I think it would be
really good for people to to realize if
that information had been free and open
that's in that's that shows informed
consent people have to understand um
that the risks when they doing something
uh even though I know this this was put
out because a lot of people were very
afraid uh when it came to the
pandemic but at least that they would
have they would have known they would
have had that information they would
have had
Choice as I say all the time where there
is risk there needs to be choice but
nothing representative
leus one of of the things following on
with that same case that really
Disturbed me was the abuse she took
afterwards so here's a young lady who
thought she was helping
Society healthy young lady thought she'd
volunteer for these trials Not only was
she harmed not only did the harms get
covered up anytime she said people were
actually abusive to her on social media
Etc if she told her story they took it
down they said it was misinformation and
stuff like that I mean
that's it it's
disgusting uh on represent
Belcher thank you madam chair and I I
just wanted to speak a little bit to the
the issue surrounding uh government
regulation and
oversight of of pharmaceutical
Industries in general um and I believe I
I mentioned the record yesterday that
the uh the FDA
commissioner um that exists that that
there was some difficulties with um as
she was being placed in that role there
was a letter writing campaign from um
moneyed interests in pharmaceutical
Industries to get her place in that
position the gentleman uh by the last
name of markx M rks that they uh
reportedly had quite a few issues with I
looked up his um his background on the
FDA website he did come from the
pharmaceutical industry where he went
then to research universities of course
they hold a lot of patents therefore a
lot of money interest before moving on
to the FDA being placed in that position
where he's in an oversight role over
this I'm seeing in various reports
suggesting that around 45% of the total
FDA budget comes from industry user fees
AKA from the pharmaceutical industry
specifically the drug division of the
FDA is financed to the tune of around
75% by the pharmaceutical industry and
what's noteworthy is there is no
Prohibition in law or in any sort of
binding ethics guidelines that prohibit
um a person from going back and forth
between a pharmaceutical or research
industry
role over to the regulatory side and
then back again creating what seems to
Ard representative
leus another
interesting thing from yesterday was the
graphs of all death
mortality and if you looked at what it
was during the height of covid when so
many people were reported as dying from
covid and then you looked at after the
vaccines were
introduced and it was higher after the
vaccines were introduced than it was at
Co the another thing that was glaringly
shocking to me and I know this is a
little aside from Co but Co has been now
listed as a childhood vaccine I do
believe if I am if I understood
everything correctly so now it uh
has the immunity of the
1986 vaccine act but was the number of
vaccines that have that children are now
between the ages of zero and I think it
was 6 months or 12
months in the past it was five and now
it's I didn't even couldn't even count
the total uh on the slide um literally I
would have been sitting here pointing my
finger about for you know trying to
count those it was just
outrageous you know
have what's changed why do we need to be
so heavily vaccinated and from in this
newborn when they're they're growing in
their immune system is adapting to their
surroundings and how do you build up an
chance represent leus following on with
that the thing that I think the thing
that struck me the most was when he was
comparing the difference between the
vaccine into in industry and the regular
um medical medicine
pharmaceutical industry and he and he
listed the top
medicines and how many
years they were under
study in before they came to Market and
then he got to
vaccines and they were days you know
five days that they tracked these
individuals and said oh you know no
problems in five days well all five days
is going to give you as if there's an
immediate an
actic you know there's not much but 5
days yeah it's fine it's safe no
problem well I am really looking forward
to the vsafe data that um and really
analyzing some of those slides that he
why and this was this is my big
why when they initially were going to do
studies the FDA was going to do one and
the CDC was going to do
another but after they got the reports
from the P I believe it was a
prr not sure if I'm saying that
correctly thank you represent beler for
that um
that the flags
were exponentially higher than than what
they thought they were going to be and
they
changed and said yeah we're just not
going to do this uh do it this way
anymore we're going to follow the FDA
now we have two separate
agencies one is policy one is
oversight going to do the same
report they should be doing two
different reports so that we understand
that we're getting the best out of that
we can
but so why when you set your criteria
for science when you're doing a science
experiment you lay out how you're going
to do it you don't change it Midstream
don't unless you don't unless you want
to manipulate the data and you don't
representative
Penza so I wanted to speak um Madam
chair just to follow up on what you said
in regards with what changed um in
regards with the childhood schedule and
the biggest thing that changed
was if prior
to the 1986 I call it 1986 the ACT if
expanded safety protocols vetting
clinical trials all of that in
that people were were able to go
after you know a company that was
producing something that caused their
their child
harm of course you're going to have only
a a you know only a small amount
that are based upon
need but vaccines are a huge industry
they are billions of dollars I mean as
we all have probably seen there's a
there's a video of Bill Gates that talks
about it and he said that was one of the
best investments that he ever got into
was in um vaccines so if you see that
it's money-making and then there's you
strip out you strip out um um liability
then what are you left with
exponentially increases increases
increases over
time and it's very sad especially
with lack of
oversight reports that were supposed to
be done mandated by the government that
were never
done we have we have statements that are
made by agencies
NOS nonprofits all of these that are
supposed to be in the in the health
field that are saying such and such
Doesn't cause this and they're saying
these things definitively saying that
there's been numerous studies D dada and
there isn't any studies that say that
it's that kind of stuff is just in a
sense it's it's lies it's propaganda and
and most people believe that and and we
have our own
our own government here locally that
that perpetuates that as well and and
those things are so concerning but we
are that the graphic that he showed was
the first year of life it went up to 12
months so there's another graphic that
shows all the way it shows further and
it went from you know whatever five to
you know there's like I think now on the
schedule to include the multiples like
the multiple shots to is got you know
CO's on the schedule with the CDC it's
not on the schedule in New
Hampshire but our New Hampshire office
links right to the CDC and those are all
offered so I believe that you're
seeing exponentially to include flu it's
it's over 70
injections so from like five in 1980 you
know prior to 198 86 all the way up to
that and um and we're not promoting what
we should be prevention in health and
supplements lifestyle all of those
things it's it's incredible to me
there's so many things that came out of
yesterday it was so long it was it was
such an incredible presentation I'd love
to capture that up and I'd want the
entire legislature um everyone in the
state to watch that because it was it
was so incredible and and in um and it
doesn't matter this is not this is not a
political thing this is about about
people having this information because
they should I know I was elected to
protect the rights of New Hampshire
citizens and this is the kind of stuff
that we should be listening to as
legislators because it is so impactful
like punch you in the face like oh my
gosh how could this
happen so you know we we have you know
our mission is covid right and the
emergency use authorization
know based on what we
saw before they rolled out the vsafe
checklist of
symptoms they already
knew
myocarditis uh heart you know death they
had had all of those things listed and
they removed every single one of them
from the checklist for
vsafe and yet nobody in the public was
privy to that
list because
we as I believe it was representative
Penza stated yesterday we did drive up
injections where people given a list of
effects our parents given a list of
vaccine informed
consent means you have been informed and
then you
consent and he is right that if we do do
not educate our elves and are not
informed and we put our
trust in our doctors and in our medical
professionals and in the people that are
at the top of our government and we
saying we instilled fear in this country
state
exponentially the mental health of
alone we're going to be dealing with for
afraid yes covid was a horrible
horrible
pandemic but this committee needs to
figure out a way for the next pandemic
on what is best for New Hampshire City
cens how do we going
forward make
sure that everybody is listened
to and that the proper professionals are
brought in on each
subject and that there is truly an
independent board
data we know that medical professionals
do not
understand mask that we
learned there are Specialists that deal
with just
that we know that social distancing was
an arbitrary
science but yet the public was led to
believe whether intentionally or not
or whether they even stated it but it
was said so everyone said well this is
do we could go grocery shopping we could
do certain things if you had a place of
employment that was considered essential
you could go to
home for me during that time I was
understand
why things were shut down why we
couldn't go outside I remember having to
go to a wedding outside and it was like
well we're really not supposed to go to
a have a wedding outside because there's
outside I think somewhere in all of this
Common Sense did not
Prevail and I thought I think we
interaction Solitude is not a good thing
for us we are social
creatures and by making
children stay
home by
themselves with no interaction with
their
travesty covering up their faces so they
Communications teachers can't really you
can say one thing but your face can say
something completely different
child there are cues that teachers take
from seeing the child's
face or how they
too I understand that we did the Swiss
cheese approach to throw everything at
it to see what we could
do but did anyone before they did that
stop to
think about all the other harms that
and I think during the next pandemic the
one of the things that we really need to
consider is because in in my I'm not a
medical professional but I've always
harm
and I don't know if we took that into
belra Madam chair I want to comment
on you know aund things that you just
said but I'm going to start with
um the list that was
known specifically for emergency youth
authorization injections the list that
was known from the big companies fizer
and madna
they knew these in
November possibly earlier but we saw you
know we saw a slide that showed
that and that none of the public knew
about that and only until lawsuits
released and I'm not we we should put
that on the record when the lawsuits
released specifically for fizer
documents nine
pages of all of the different side
effects no one knew any of that but the
ones that they did know which were big
uh pericarditis you know all of that um
and it was a long
list and for them to come out with be
safe and have things like fever nauseous
like those things are not they're not
critical and they should have had you
know the radio buttons on vsafe with
those other and they didn't um but that
all comes to the whole piece of informed
consent and so when we were
using you massive amounts we you know
this whole uptick of trying to get
everyone you know in the state injected
and and people were they were horrible
to each
other um say saying you know did you get
you know have you been vaccinated have
you been vaccinated oh my gosh I mean
just asking random people you'd walk
into a store and people would ask if
you're it was crazy there was no such
thing as as personal medical privacy
anymore there was nothing it was out the
window but I know for a fact from a
pharmacist that there was
absolutely zero informed
consent at a pharmacy uh this is a very
large Pharmacy actually a chain
um there was no handout that gave that
list that he was talking about that the
pharmaceutical companies knew
were specific adverse serious adverse
side effects that's informed consent and
they knew that information from their 6
months or so of clinical
trials that is it right there that's to
me where the rubber meets the road
there's no questions asked everyone
should have had that information so for
every Mall every you know New Hampshire
Motor Speedway drive-thru every single
person before they had an injection in
their arm should have had a piece of
paper that said you need to
know in a sense that you are part of
this massive experiment because they are
because we didn't have enough data to
know what was going to
happen so they were in a sense part of a
clinical trial and they should have
known hey this is what we know right now
we're still moving forward with this
it's under emergency use it's not
authorized all of the you all the data
is not out but you have to know before
you do this and not any of those people
did and I don't know what those numbers
are here in New Hampshire we have 1.4
million people last I knew we were in
the we were up WS of when this was all
going on in 2021 and
2022 um when people were getting first
shot second shot and boosters uh it was
we were close to I believe 80% of in the
State 70 possibly 80% that were um that
had been injected at that
point so to me that is with no informed
consent these people were going into
something blind they were you know a lot
of people were fear had fear some of
them were if they had to keep their job
were bullied or shamed or whatever into
getting it and it was awful I remember
talking to I need to get her name
because I'd love her to come testify um
a police
officer and even though that they were
protected here in the state see that's
the key you know nobody they say oh well
they weren't forced whatever but it was
like they were
forced cuz if you were the the only one
in your department that
wasn't how they were treated was awful
she was shamed and bullied by other by
upper
management especially with masking and
things like that it was just it was
awful and so she succumbed to it and
she's vaccine injured young woman
doesn't think she's ever going to be
able to have children now horrible story
there's some of us that ran for office
because of this and and from hearing
these stories and I'm one of them and um
but just listening to that to me I think
more than anything else and I'd like to
know what our state knew did our state
know those serious adverse effects and
we did not in our massive efforts of
giving everyone injected did we not
provide that information
public represent
Bela thank you madam chair and I would
tend to uh concur with all I've heard
thus far here and I would like to go a
little deeper into some things and talk
about perhaps propose some things that
we might consider um we do have albeit
not total we do have some power and some
Authority given our circumstance at the
moment and I think we should consider
utilizing some of it in order to
properly do this some things I'd like us
to look at if we would agree would be to
uh send out some questions to certain
parties to see if we can get some
answers specifically I would like to see
us send some questions to uh pertinent
Federal
Regulators as well as uh certain
pharmaceutical um corporations who were
involved in some of the data we found
out yesterday I would like to find out
some specific information I would like
to um I would like to request access to
the entirety of data from the vs
analysis and the vsafe analysis as well
as all methodologies used to determine
safety
signals I would like to ask them point
blank when was the first time you became
aware that a safety signal existed
using either or both methods that were
outlined for um the vaccines in
question I would like to request
information from the pharmaceutical
companies as to why they decided to
immediately vaccinate the control group
after approximately two months over the
preferences that were expressed by the
Food and Drug Administration now there's
limited we obviously are a little
Limited in trying to um trying to obtain
this information if it is not something
that's willingly given but I think
there's no harm whatsoever in trying to
receive this
information uh beyond that we have a
little more power when it comes to this
but I would like to find out if any New
Hampshire Regulators or executive
Personnel had access to any of these
data um when it comes to the vaccines in
real or near real time as it was rolled
out I would like to know if DHHS had
access to these databases if they were
aware of any safety signals that existed
or were being exceeded um and if so when
they became aware of them I would like
to know now what they believe as in
terms of these safety signals and the
methodologies that were being used by
the FDA and
CDC and I would like to ask them what
their current opinion is on the safety
and and efficacy um of the vaccines
especially the MRNA vaccines in question
given the data that we've seen from
yesterday
um on to the next item uh yesterday I
had my mind repeatedly blown by a lot of
this data that came out um a lot of my
own personal understandings and
narratives were challenged in some of
the information I'm still working
through it it's going to take some time
but now I'd like to return the favor and
blow up a few narratives myself so I'd
like to read into the record quickly not
in total just by um by
title from the uh United States
Congress the staff report on the
committee of the Judiciary and the
select subcommittee on the weaponization
of the federal government United States
House of Representatives the
weaponization of ciza how a cyber
security agency colluded with big Tech
and disinformation partners to censor
Americans and this report Det details in
some uh in some depth including uh and
there's other uh articles and whatnot
about this as well you can find um about
how the uh federal government appears to
have through the organization CA
cisa the cyber security and
infrastructure or cyber and
infrastructure security Association I'll
find out exactly what that means but
they uh they they worked directly with
in industry Partners in non-governmental
organizations um and they had Direct
access uh through custommade
applications and communication
software um including um with the FBI
and other intelligence agencies to uh
big tech companies uh such as Google
such as the social media
companies in which they utilized
information Warfare
techniques to censor uh Americans who
had who were expressing their own
stories about what happened to them
after receiving vaccines or other items
that uh had to do with covid and
government actions during
covid um they even had analysis of
techniques to use to automate the
process of targeting narratives as they
were developing before they could take
off and Achieve any sort of um social
hold as well as putting out information
that was um their preferred narrative
that appears in hindsight to have been
patently false um and again this is this
is an official government document from
the federal government can you
see that oh sure this uh this was from
June 26 2023 this particular report
could you forward that to the committee
abely it will be forwarded to the
committee um so that's one interesting
thing that I think deserves to be looked
at a little bit and even more recently
just in this last week I would like to
also read into the record and these ones
I have already sent to the
committee um based on the
report of the another report from the
United States House of
Representatives titled an evaluation of
the evidence surrounding Eco Health
Alliance Incorporated research
activities
um this report of May 1st
2024 documents the um extreme violations
of policy and perhaps law I would argue
um by the corporation Eco Health
Alliance this was a described as an
intermediary or pass through
Organization for Grant making they
received taxpayer funds from the United
States federal government for which to
then make grants according to United
States law and policy set forth by the
NIH and FDA um um research what for for
folks what is the NIH the National
Institutes of Health which is the
organization that had been run by um
Anthony fouchy or perhaps still is I'm
not did he retire I'm not sure we'll
find that out
um anyway this organization was a pass
the organization that makes grants for
medical research now uh gain of function
research uh is something that is
prohibited under federal law as being
excessively dangerous and what it does
is it involves
taking uh pathogens such as viruses and
manipulating their genomes and their
characteristics such that they gain
functions that they in theory might
someday come to gain through natural
processes but they through this
non-natural selective process that they
engineer um caused them to gain uh
rapidly things such as increased virence
in increased transmissibility the
ability to jump from Human to
human um representative Bel Belcher
wasn't that one of the questions I
believe and I'm not positive that was
circulating out there during covid that
people were saying was you know thought
that this might be a gain of function
indeed and this this significantly this
report plays into that question because
it was asked of a number of people
during various Congressional testimonies
whether there was gain of function
research funded at the Wuhan Institute
of virology in Wuhan China by the uh
organization Eco Health Alliance as an
intermediary from the National
Institutes of Health the answer was
given as no there was no gain of
function research however this report
finds that that testimony was not
accurate there was gain of function
research funded by the United States
taxpayers through the intermediary Eco
Health Alliance against federal law in a
foreign military laboratory the uh Wuhan
Institute of virology is a military
laboratory of the people's Liberation
Army of the Chinese Communist Party um
is Dr fouchi associated with either the
National Institute of Health or the
equal Alliance yes uh Dr fouchi was um
perhaps still is but he certainly was um
the head of the NIH and and the the
individual who would have ultimately
been responsible for
approving um such Grant making he held a
lot of money um available to him to make
uh grants to uh other entities with so
they would have been approved um whether
or not he specifically approved funding
to The Institute of virology or the
Wuhan Institute is another story because
there's some suggestion here that this
was sort of something that was being
done by Eco Health Alliance um perhaps
without the knowledge of the federal
government or perhaps with it's hard to
it's hard to know exactly but they were
nonetheless in violation of Law and as a
result of this
the Department of Health and Human
Services office of the secretary
Washington DC in this letter dated uh
where is it
bottom I don't see a date I'll find the
date but it's from the last rough
roughly weak um they have noticed the
suspension and proposed debarment of
Ecco Health Alliance from any further
receipt of taxpayer funding as an
intermediary to fund these um various
medical research programs based on their
gross violation and not just violation
but this details how they repeatedly
requested information during the covid
pandemic of Ecco Health Alliance because
there were allegations that were
considered credible that the Wuhan
Institute of virology developed the SARS
cove2 virus in their laboratory from
which it spilled and that that funding
may have been paid for by the American
taxpayer through Eco Health Alliance Eco
Health Alliance stonewalled this
investigation refusing to provide the
documents that would have demonstrated
the truth or the falsity of this claim
and that's the reason for their uh
suspension and dis Department do we know
how much money has been given to that
organization I'm sure we can find that
out I don't have it off top of my head
here um I just want to say something
about the social media aspect that you
were talking about
now you know people say oh yeah you're
being censored on I mean I don't use
social media so I'm very illiterate when
it comes to that so you know we're being
censored on Facebook or we're being
censored on Twitter or um whatever other
social media is out there um and you
know I'd say well you know maybe a
little you know maybe somebody's doing
something
offensive
however we have heard testimony after
testimony in this committee and I have
heard numerous complaints from
constituents on how they can no longer
post on something or their posts are
being taken taken down or you can't
etc we are supposed to be a free country
and freedom of
speech is our First Amendment
right I understand that our
distinguished guests yesterday said that
they are private companies and they can
do what they
want
ever if they're going to censor our
first amendment rights they should put
that in
there right at when you're signing up
that we have the right and maybe it's in
the small fine
print but they should list what type of
speech they're going to
censor not just arbitrarily oh this time
we're going to censor this type of
speech and tomorrow we're going to
censor that type of speech because what
what I find when people are censoring
things or prohibiting things and you
know I'll just use an analogy I told my
children
once my son said you know Mom mosquitoes
should be
outlawed I said you know that makes
perfect sense I I think that's a great
idea I said
however what if someone said snakes
should be outlawed and you like snakes
well that wouldn't be very good I said
see how it
works you may not think something is
good and should be outlawed and somebody
else will say yeah I agree with you but
then eventually they'll get around to
what you think should stay and they want
outlawed it's pretty simple um he got it
represent Bela representative leus first
and then
representative thank you I think trust
is the thing
um or the destruction of trust I think
is going to be is and is going to be
much more harmful in the future than a
lot of other things my dad told me when
I was a little
girl that as long as you always told the
truth people would always trust whatever
you said and there would be a time when
yeah what you said might be doubtful but
if you were known for always telling the
truth truth you would be
believed but if you only once told a lie
that trust would take a really long time
of telling the truth to come
back
because ever after that people would be
like but is this one of those times
right and unfortunately what we've seen
throughout this whole pandemic and with
testimony that we've gotten is there was
an awful lot
of sometimes overt lies and sometimes
just lies through
Omission um misleading
information
and like for instance with the young
lady we were talking about who had wait
darn she had a feeding tube she was in a
wheelchair all kinds of things and that
was that was part of the trials right
and those were the injuries that were
almost immediately obvious and she
continued downhill and how did it get
reported abdominal
pain abdominal pain she's got a feeding
tube she's in wheelchair she can't do
anything and it's abdominal pain but
and oh I'm sorry not only that
represented leus it wasn't just that she
had abdominal pain it was that the
investigator said he didn't
feel that it was related didn't feel
when it happened almost immediately yes
but but um the idea that covid came from
a lab right I knew that in
2019 that information was put out
shortly after it went out I read There
were links to the Papers written by the
doctor who created it there were paper
Paths of the money that was given to
them there were documents as to the fact
that that lab was not secure and ran the
risk of of um Biologicals getting out
all that information was there and that
the Chinese government when they found
out that they had succeeded said shut it
all down get rid of it all
that was in
2019 and then to have the federal
government our government
including fouchi from the NIH who was in
charge of giving that
money to that
organization right because it had to go
through him um oh no it was natural and
all of that I mean it was supposedly a
conspiracy theory that nothing more than
that that it was manufactured but we
already knew that I saw that evidence in
2019 so I remember when they were saying
that I was like what the heck are they
talking about they know where this came
from I know where this came from and it
thing and thing and thing after that I
had read a I had a there was a um study
that hospital had
done about why ventilators were not the
proper response and how it could
actually be killing people and what they
were doing research they found a lot of
clots and stuff they found that vitamin
C massive vitamin C would help prevent
that all kinds of information I posted
that not a commentary on it the study
and got
misinformation and that got the link to
that disappeared Etc that was facts that
people needed to know that was a real
study by a real Hospital that would
potentially have saved people's lives
but it was being shut down it was not
being distributed and why do you think
that
is uh if I had to make a guess I'd say
money that's what we keep seeing follow
the money follow the money somebody was
going to
benefit like for instance if there was
no treatment and that's another thing
all these treatments that these doctor
doctors were finding and coming up with
and we've heard from medical doctors Etc
the treatments iorc and hydro
hydro whatever you know what I'm saying
hydroxy
chloroquin treatments that were
working and yet that became a no no you
couldn't say that you'd lose your
license etc etc pharmacists couldn't
even have it in you know to fill
prescriptions and that also I mean I
think that was because while they made
an awful lot of money on vaccines and
some of the other treatments new
treatments that they came up with and if
we had had treatments that would work we
could not have done an
eua we could not have allowed that vac
those vaccines they would not have been
Lial
free because we had another
treatment as long as we had another
treatment we couldn't do that and here's
my problem with all of
that we may have another pandemic in the
future who's going to
believe what should be done right and
that's the big harm that I see in
telling all these lie after lie after
lie not only were people
killed or died who didn't need to be
if we have in the future a pandemic that
is very
dangerous much more so than this proved
to
be um who's going to
listen when they say do this or don't do
this who's going to listen we have lost
the trust of the people and that could
be very harmful in the future and my
question is how are we going to get it
back well that is a great question
because you know I've Been Told your
word is everything right that's
basically all you
have and once you lose
that you
know I know people that have lost trust
in doctors because they no longer trust
what they're saying because of either
misdiagnosis or they feel that you know
um they're prescrib their first reaction
is just prescribe a medicine instead of
treat the cause it's let's treat the
symptom
um so I I
mean it is going to be incredibly
tough you know it's okay to say you know
gee I made a mistake or I changed my
mind or I found out new
information but just to squelch it and
deny the people in this country we are
supposed to be the freest country in the
world in the
world and we suppressed speech we
suppressed
ideas how do we accomplish great things
in this country because we collaborate
with ideas you have people you discuss
opposing ideas and usually the best
Solutions come when two opposing parties
come together and figure something out
that's how we advance things in this
country there's no one right way for
everything and to to only listen to one
side is
Penza so representative luus the stuff
that you said I think is
um is huge I mean so many of the things
one even more so how would we ever
believe anything
again I don't think that we have the
opportunity
to only because we can't get the message
out so here we are in New Hampshire when
all this started if let's just you know
all we're going to talk about is
co and
so you know in March all the stuff
happens the hype you know you know a lot
of people were like okay you know I'll
do my two weeks and all that and
then some of us that had some you know
kind of insight and started to dig right
away we're like okay this is um this is
this is not going away and then I
realized very quickly after about four
weeks that that the schools weren't
going to open back up and it was this is
this is how they're going to literally
trample on everybody's civil liberties
the problem is and let's just focus on
New
Hampshire we didn't have and we still
don't have one
unbiased media outlet that is providing
any of this
information and I don't need to mention
any names or whatever but we know who we
know who the one television station is
that does all the reporting and they
don't come out with any of that there's
a spin or whatever and very political
bias and and then pretty much all of the
mainstream
newspapers there's about four or five
and then the rest are online are not
providing this kind of information so
how would you you have you we would have
to be able to get that out we had almost
247 you know we had a we had a governor
and and state epidemiologist and all of
these people that were you know uh DHHS
Lor shanet at the time pounding weekly
sometimes even more than that a
narrative over and over and over and
over and over again where the rest of
that media newspaper the television was
was all lock
step and if that doesn't change in 60%
70% of with the one .4 million in New
Hampshire if that's all they're
listening to and they don't listen to
any of the other side because they can't
hear it it's squelched and it still is
squelched you cannot search anywhere on
Google and find this
information doctors react 19 I can um
the
flccc you need to know it to find it
Epoch times has some great things that's
more of a national thing they they've
really put out a lot of different things
that have come out whether it be doctors
and studies and stuff with covid which
has been wonderful treatments showing uh
you know you know early on vitamin D uh
talked about vitamin um vitamin B niin
all these other types of things which is
wonderful but that's a paid um entity
and you can't just get that you know
most of these too even conquered monitor
um uh The Fosters Daily Democrat where I
am where I'm located those are all
behind a pay wall and there's such a
small percentage of people that are that
have access to that not many people read
um you know read the newspaper uh you
know my generation and
younger um they spend a lot of time on
social media like social media news
outlets where you can get some stuff but
that's still missing you know I would
have to say 70 to 80% or more of New
Hampshire is not going to know this kind
of stuff how many people are going to
actually know about this hearing like
they're not following they're not
tracking so how could we really change
that that to me is where it has to come
from the top so whether you need a
governor that's speaking that whether
you need um an agency that's speaking
that full
transparency and where we have a
legislature that passes laws to demand
it
is important too yesterday a lot of
things came out with some some
legislation this is Nob brainer
legislation whether it means um your
right of conscience or if it's religious
or whatever for whatever reason you
don't want to have an injection or a
medical uh procedure or whatever that is
the utmost liberty
interest those are the things that
nonpartisan so I just I don't
know how we can get there with what
you're talking about unless it it comes
from that I mean I always say you know
pull all our money together and and make
our own kind of you know news site or
whatever because it's trying to come
compete with the same ones that we
censoring and all of that because
they're advertisers are the same
entities that are um they're making the
money so
they're it's you know it's never going
to happen they're they're being paid so
I just I don't see a huge amount of
change there unless our federal
government can stop that too you know it
was talked about a little bit yesterday
but we're one of the
only one of the only countries and other
countries kind of I guess look at us and
and somewhat laugh at us how we let um
pharmaceutical companies um drug
companies have these
commercials I mean they're
constant just repeating whatever drug
they're trying to pedal and um and then
we laugh in our household we don't watch
a lot of TV but we laugh at the end of
those commercials because then it's like
okay well suicide and death and suicidal
thoughts and uh and stroke and heart
attack and but but before that it was
like this wonderful everything's so
wonderful there you know running through
a garden a field and oh by the way all
of these side effects because they have
to give them but you know we're kind of
a joke we make our our for having that
level and those type that type of money
that's the money that controls news that
controls the narrative and we stay in a
kind of a Perpetual state so I think
what you said is so important though is
who are we going to trust some of the
best doctor
the ones that were that always
trusted and that said hey this worked
for my
patient oh my gosh they lost everything
licenses and all that in a free country
so I don't I don't know how we can
dismantle that medical industrial
complex these hospitals protocols they
were paid
more money for a covid tagged
death for a CO positive patient for
certain protocols do we have actual data
supporting that there is data that
supports that and um but I want to make
sure that it's it's absolutely factual
um what we have I I have some things but
it's I I need to know those Source
documents I believe that some of the
speakers that we've had here can help us
with that we do need to know that um
yeah if we want to make sure that it's
factual um and if you can uh email it to
those documents to the committee so that
we can put them in the record that would
be great there was a chart that came out
over a year ago Yuri you might be
familiar with it remember it gave every
state and it gave uh it gave an amount
just because you're on HHS and gave an
amount that hospitals were paid per
covid death and and uh you know some
some were in over 100,000 for you know
um so but I we need to know what their
that Source document is so it would be
good for our committee to find that
information uh represent p is
off um I have a couple of questions that
uh I would offer for discussion so first
one is uh we're talking about possible
way we see
our um legislation should go but uh next
Thursday we have Senate Bill 402 which
have a good chances of passing and uh uh
New Hampshire General Court basically
wants to give more authority to FDA and
CDC and and say uh that uh
uh basically our authority to
review vaccinations uh that pharmacist
are allowed to
administer uh we we will uh we will
cancer Authority of New Hampshire
general court and just say if FDA and
CDC feels that those vaccines are good
so go ahead and administer them so just
your your sort like
about uh I mean counter argument is that
local politicians that we are not
doctors we are not medical professionals
so we should not make those medical
decisions so let's uh let FDA and
CDC do it and
basically uh as we heard yesterday and
in some other testimonies
uh it might be not the best decision so
just your thoughts on on
that could you just explain a you know
what are you
saying as I'm not familiar with the bill
um as you are because this is I'm saying
your area of expertise more so than um
that we are going to be giving more
authority to the
FDA versus having our own state
look into these things is that basically
what you just said oh basically uh maybe
it's more mild issue it's more like
before we could say no to to a certain
in a certain situation of Pharmacists
administering uh certain new vaccines
for example and now we're saying no no
uh New Hampshire General Court won't be
involved anymore it will be all uh all
according to FDA and
CDC so te technically they're taking
away all our our Authority as
legislators in regards to protecting the
citizens of New Hampshire is that
correct yeah yeah yes that's how I see
it but unfortunately uh the way I feel
the majority of legislature see it the
other way so not not sure well I think
maybe we should all have them watch the
uh testimony from
yesterday or at least suggest it or
maybe somebody can go through and pick
out Snippets and share with the general
court so that they have an idea of what
they're voting
on I I know for me personally it was an
eyeopener I had no idea about a lot of
that um probably because my children are
older and
um I react to medicines very poorly so
I'm always
no and have been so I'm probably
fortunate um that I've had that um me
mentality um only because of reactions
um and you know when we speak about that
right like I had a woman come in when we
were talking about covid uh vaccine and
she's like you
know i' take the
vaccine if they just told me what was in
it because she can no longer get the flu
vaccine because of the inert not the
actual ingredient but the inert
ingredients that are in it in it the
inactive ingredients and she's like I
just I'll take it but I want to know
what the inactive ingredients are and
she could not get it and it was going to
cost a her
job and she was concerned because if she
had another reaction like she had with
the flu shot she would
die so her choice
was get the vaccine chance dying cuz we
don't know what's in it or keeping my
job I don't know let me think think
about that for a
moment you know it's a really it was a
really difficult I mean
obviously her life meant more than her
job but that also caused a hardship for
her
family we didn't give her much of a
choice she was wanted to get it she just
wanted to know the ingredients and we
couldn't even give her
that representative beler
thank you madam chair and just to return
for a moment to the um to the issue of
some of the censorship that occurred uh
social media issues and whatnot I do
recall when I um when I was injured uh
in the aftermath of my vaccination I I
tried to share uh just a factual story
of what happened to me what my
experience was um and based on so-called
misinformation policies I was suspended
from social media and I would not
allowed I was not allowed to return to
social media until I deleted the posts
in question now at the time I certainly
didn't know this I I I thought that they
were just these social media companies
following along with sort of a what what
was seemed like a moral imperative that
was being socially pushed on them but
now we know I think quite factually
given the information in the
Congressional report I just read into
the record that these instructions and
these narratives of of how to censor and
what to censor and what was preferable
to have out there
publicly it originated with the federal
government it originated with the uh
with ciza and with individuals from the
FBI and
doj so represent Bel I just want to
interrupt you for one moment and and
forgive me for doing that so it wasn't
actually the social media companies that
were making this
decision uh at least it's very it's very
arguable that it was not now now was
there an enforcement mechanism from the
federal government to force them to do
this I don't know if that's clear yet
but it is clear that there was an
attempt at coercion at the very least
from the federal government they
designed software where they had Direct
portals using a a software system that
they open on their computers that
allowed them to transmit Direct ly to
Personnel at big companies such as
Facebook and Twitter where they would
they would give them lists of people and
topics that they wanted removed and
censored from their
platforms and this went directly to
often what we're called trust and safety
teams rather
dystopian at these organizations where
they would then act on them and this
again this is not this is not
speculation this is factual there's a
current ly a lawsuit pending as well
called Missouri versus Biden and this
lawsuit is currently pending before The
Supreme Court I don't know if they've
issued CT on this yet um a lower court
judge identified in this in his finding
and in the injunction that he placed on
the federal government he said and I'm
paraphrasing but he said this is the
biggest first imminent violation in this
nation's
history that the censorship was
outrageous what was occurring and again
I believe this is pending right now
before the Supreme Court um I think
they're going to take this up probably
in this next year uh and hopefully
something something good and more
information will come out of this uh but
yeah we we know that this was not a
private company making private decisions
without any outside influence this was a
government influence
censorship campaign and narrative
campaign to build a certain narrative
and we know this was uh This was done
actually in coordination with other
other countries too this was done in
coordination with the five eyes Nations
it was done with uh with MI5 in Britain
uh this was not a standalone effort the
entire Western world seems to have
thrown the very concept of of freedom of
speech and freedom of conscience and
freedom of religion all of those things
just kind of went out the window and to
speak to what you you said earlier you
you you gave a listing of of how they
ignored certain harms and focused
exclusively on this one thing and and
there's actually a word for that the
word is
safetyism safetyism is when you become
myopic and you focus exclusively on one
harm without weighing the counterveiling
considerations that will come with any
action you take cuz we know that
anything the government does or does not
do comes with both intended and
unintended consequences and it just it
just appears right now that that those
unintended consequences and other things
were ignored because this became a as we
heard yesterday A A certainly
ideological and perhaps even borderline
religious um
conviction of mitigating covid at any
cost so so a couple things is one um
that judges ruling the lower court uh
could we could you email that to the
committee yes I'll find that uh that
would be great um just so we can have
that uh you know for backup and to uh
substantiate what we're discussing here
um the other thing is is you know um my
family Co went through our family early
on um right at the beginning of the
whole pandemic and the
shutdowns and
[Music]
um so we you know when the vaccines came
around we figured you know
immune our immune system was pretty good
um at that time but there was a lot of
controversy about that but you know what
yesterday was when he
said well
if you get the covid vaccine they
finally admitted that you still can
transmit
covid how long did they deny
that how long did they know that it
would be
transmissible once the
injection you were given the
injection how long did they know that
you could still get covid even if you
got the
vaccine or the covid
shot how long did they know about
that and I think you know I think once
it came out that you could people
started getting covid after being
vaccinated I I think the new narrative
symptoms but if we look at the charts
and the death rates I don't
represent P off yeah and just anecdote
my Koka and his
daughter um I think probably he
understood that his daughter is
not risk uh population and maybe he
himself is young enough but he was
definitely getting vaccine for himself
and covid vaccine for his daughter
because his wife was
uh immun compromised how old is his
daughter
please so uh about 10 years old
uh uh so uh uh child a child so so the
point being yes uh people were not
informed that and many
people even if they understood the risk
or of vaccination they felt that they
are protecting vulnerable relatives or
vulnerable populations and they were not
case right I think we heard here from um
Dr kulor that
really the target group were was the
older population um that we really
needed to be concerned about and they
were the ones that really needed to be
um
protected uh and
vaccinated um so
uh and as an infectious disease doctor
and hearing him talk about that and
talking about how technically I think he
said anyone like under 40 or maybe it's
even
50 really the risk of covid is
compared to what he's I believe I'm not
I don't want to put words in his mouth
but I think the the risk benefit uh is
there and that nobody under the age of
50 I believe he he believes should be
getting
vaccinated so
[Music]
um and this is not a doctor who is
against vaccines because he does believe
in vaccines and he believes in people
getting vaccinated
but he also believes I I think you know
listening to his testimony that there
are Target populations for different
vaccines so did
uh represent Belcher thank you madam
chair and since I've brought it up and I
will I will forward this to the
committee will'll become part of the
official record I just wanted to quote
quickly from that lower court decision
that I've got it in front of me in the
case Missouri versus Biden in the
Judgment attached to the inj Junction
the present case arguably involves the
most massive attack against free speech
in United States history in their
attempts to suppress alleged
disinformation the federal government
and a particularly defendants named
herein and there is quite the list of
defendants are alleged to have blatantly
ignored the first amendment's right to
free speech although the censorship
alleged in this case almost exclusively
targeted conservative speech the issues
herein raised beyond go beyond party
lines
and the list of people enjoined and as a
part of this includes almost
every almost every Federal agency that
we would be looking at here including
not just FBI and CA but also the NIH the
others I will make one point um and this
has been said um from a lot of our
speakers is is that New Hampshire did
pretty
good
um so uh I just want to make sure that
um we got some things right I I don't
ever want to say that we got it all
wrong and I don't
think
um this is a learning curve for all of
us
here um but go but next time we need to
do better um and I think that what we
need to understand is that there were
conflicting information um being given
out um as we heard in testimony from the
commissioner of Education he was given
guidance to schools and they were opted
not to follow the state guidance which
was less restrictive and following
Federal
guidance um which was more restri
restrictive um
population it's very hard to
discern which way to
and fear does play an important point in
our
lives but it can't rule our
lives and I think that's what happened
everything and I think that is something
that can never ever ever happen
again there is always has to be
something to look forward
to there has to be
gratitude there is always something to
be grateful
today and I think that we as public
servces and as the
government we need to understand that
we have
to yes things can be bad but there's
always
something even if it's the tiniest thing
that we can be grateful for or that's
positive and we need to make sure we
outline those
positives represent
leus following on that and
fear
um fear keeps us safe quickly at the
moment moment tells us jump out of the
way of the car Etc I mean it has a good
a reason why we have it but there's a
been a lot there is a lot of evidence we
know that it fear
also interferes with making rational
logical decisions it acts as you know
it's that back part of our brain right
that keeps us
alive but it also interferes with with
that front part of our brain that
reasons
and I I
believe that
fear stirring fear increasing fear was
intentional on the part of various
members of our
government and as
example if you listen very carefully to
the things that f for instance said he
would always say well this could happen
or this might cause this or whatever
when we know now it really didn't and
doesn't and you can see that for a long
time for instance during the AIDS
epidemic he said
well children might be able to get AIDS
from coming in contact with somebody who
has it right casual contact well we know
that wasn't the case we pretty much knew
that wasn't the case then but and he
pretty much knew that wasn't the case
then so by say but by saying it might
happen it could be everybody takes that
as oh my goodness and then look at all
of the AIDS patients who were
abandoned who had to survive alone whose
relatives friends Etc were terrified to
come and visit them because they might
get a s now see that's one of those lies
of
omission he was right I guess it could
maybe it was a possibility but by saying
those things over and over it instilled
fear in people it made it a big deal and
this is what we saw over and over with
Co all the things that could be might be
you know those wordings were very
careful I listened to those and I said
hm didn't say these are the odds we have
evidence whatever he said this might be
this could be and it was all to build
population
so Wow first I'm going to say because
here we have someone that already did
again and I can tell you from personal
experience that that is true my mom
her
however I called a doctor friend of mine
and said you know I've had
covid um what do you think he like well
when did you have it I told him and he
goes yep no no problem so I would go
over and bring her whatever she needed
and make sure she was okay and stuff I
never got covid from her but if I didn't
go she would have been
her how many other people or parents or
elderly
people had that happened to them and
didn't have anyone to go and visit with
them I mean I would have gone anyways
whether but I just wanted to double
check what my chances were of getting
you know if I would get Co again um but
is that was the narrative my
dad was taken to the hospital at the
very beginning of when covid
happened um right after the lockdowns
and I will never forget and thank God
for the paramedics that's all I can say
is thank God for them they made sure
that he took his phone I don't know if
he has an iPad might have an iPad and
his charges they said take those with
you if they did not do that we would
have had no and I mean no communication
with him at all we were not allowed to
go to the hospital we were not allowed
to see him we were allowed
isolated and guess what he didn't have
oh co he did not have
covid but yet at that time he was
treated like he was did and we were
banned from seeing him fortunately
because of the param iics were able to
communicate with him and talked to him
via Zoom or whatever he had on his
iPhone but that's because we had
people that told us told him what to
take with him to make sure that we would
have
communication how many people didn't
have someone tell them that and they
were alone that did have covid and did
die
alone without their family and those
goodbye representative leus and then
represent beler I just want
to remind all of us I guess that in the
beginning we didn't know there was a lot
we didn't know and so we were being
super super careful and that was a good
thing because if this if this disease
would have Pro proven to be as deadly to
the whole
populace as we thought the things we did
in the beginning were good but fairly
quickly fairly quickly and and from
things we've been hearing I think there
was a lot more known at that point um
than was being leted out but because the
people who know those things or knew
those things weren't letting it out the
majority of people the majority
officials the majority of doctors Etc
were doing the best they could and what
they were doing I think made sense for
the first little bit but then as we knew
it was the elderly Etc as we knew that
children were not actually going to
spread covid to their
grandmas um because they didn't get
it
then the fact should I mean we should
have been
informed all along as we knew so we
could say okay we did the best we could
there we now know this let's do this and
I think that's the problem is that we
stuck with that protocol even after we
knew it didn't work it wasn't
appropriate I mean in the beginning we
washed everything right and then we
found out that we actually it's not it's
not
um you can't get it from surfaces right
and but we still kept up that protocol
even though we had learned that's not
how it spread and a lot of things like
that and that's people have to be
willing I think to say okay I did the
best I could with what I knew I now knew
other know other things I was wrong you
know and and this is what I know now and
this is what we should do but it just
seems like there's a lot of pride in not
wanting to admit
that they said the wrong thing or a
mistake was made well everybody makes
mistakes I think the the problem is when
you're not willing to admit it and move
on from there I mean you respect
somebody who says okay with the
information I had you know I made this
decision it was the wrong decision I now
have this misinformation go forward and
today that's part of I think what we
need to do to begin to get some trust
back is for people
to be willing to to say I made a mistake
about this I was wrong about that this
is what I know now this is you know but
we don't seem
to we don't seem to allow people to
change their mind or change or anything
anything you see that in the news all
the time somebody who used to believe
one way then you see they say oh you
know I've learned this since then and
now I believe this way and what happens
the news social media everybody attacks
them constantly yeah well they used to
you know whatever and they're just fakes
and all kinds of stuff it's like no
they're humans we make the best
decisions we can with the information we
have as we get more information we
change our mind I H hardly agree and I
think that if that had happened early on
we wouldn't be having the discussion
about
trust I said but they
didn't and they're still trying not to
and that that is the biggest problem uh
representative
Belcher thank you madam chair I'd like
to offer a perhaps counterintuitive
Silver Lining to some of the things that
have happened and that silver lining
that piece of good news for me is that
trust in government and established
media has
collapsed collapsed through the floor
news we government are not to be
trusted for those watching we sitting
here we are not your friends and we are
not your family we have power power over
you that means you need to watch us
because power corrupts you do not trust
government you watch government and you
make sure it doesn't get out of control
the trouble now comes
in with the fact that what we've seen in
some of the documents I've read in this
morning and previously is that we are
dealing with not just collapse in
government uh trust we're also dealing
with collapse in institutional
trust that is a real
problem so what we need to be looking at
I think is why and H what we can do
about that and I think it's entirely
clear based on these things that there
is
anti-competitive Cel
behavior that is being conducted in both
the private sector and the public sector
at the federal level especially um in
what are commonly known these days as uh
public private
Partnerships and I I would only add in
here a quote that
um the according to bino musolini the
definition of fascism is the combination
of state and corporate power so I would
I would throw that out there
but we have a collusion happening with
and this is demonstrated in the house
documents I read into the record that
government is working with Nos and
private companies to affect cartel
Behavior to control narratives to do
censorship and to do to push certain
ideas and to keep things out of the
public
record now let me read from you our
charge as a legislature under New
Hampshire Constitution Article 83 we are
charged with crushing and I quote
conspiracy Monopoly and any other unfair
means of Market manipulation this is in
the New Hampshire Constitution we have a
charge to do it as a legislature and is
within our power to do this so I think
that is something that we can look at
down the road either in our report or as
we may come back next year and introduce
legislation what can be done to stifle
the cartel behavior that is eroding
public trust in our public
institutions in order that we don't have
a total collapse in society because
trust in government shouldn't be there
important thank you for that
clarification and and thank you uh
representative beler for citing uh that
article uh article 83 from the New
Hampshire Constitution I think that's
extremely uh
powerful
um always being one to believe in
transparency no matter where it may lead
um whether I agree or not agree uh I
think is essential to good
governance um truth and labeling
informed
consent
Etc should be something
that New Hampshire should strive to be
on The Cutting Edge
charge because if we are to live up to
our
motto which is Live Free or Die but
death is not the worst of all evils
everywhere Will O be the only
way that citizens of New
Hampshire can make informed
decisions and know
exactly what they're signing up for
Penza Madam chair I agree with
everything that you just said and I
wanted to comment on uh representative
uh leus and representative Belcher there
all these points that have been given
previously I don't use my litmus test as
okay well New Hampshire wasn't we did we
did some things right we did some things
wrong New Hampshire wasn't as or many
people have said New Hampshire wasn't as
bad as oh this state that worst state
whether it be you know a lot of people
talk about how bad New York was how bad
other states were I don't I don't go
based upon that every single person that
is in our
government especially our
executive took an oath to both New
Hampshire Constitution first and the US
Constitution Second
and I have to say that when this was all
going down that's what I followed and
there weren't many in this country and I
don't give a pass I don't care if you
trampled on one right or a h 100 none of
it should have ever happened
because you were elected the the people
are the ones that hold the trust they're
the ones that are managing they're the
ones that are the boss they're they're
basically
they're the boss and we work for
them Christy gome in South
Dakota and there's probably a lot of
different videos and things that you
could read about but I saw her in person
and she spoke on this directly whether
you like her or not I'm only talking
about how she handled
specifically covid when it came to
Federal money protocols and all of that
she literally said in this meeting she
took out right in the early on she took
out her Constitution she read it
thoroughly she wanted to know exactly
where her Authority
rested she didn't do all those executive
orders she didn't do any of that they
money it was quite
incredible and she wanted to make sure
that she stayed within her Authority
versus New Hampshire with over our
governor had over a 100 emergency and
executive orders and that was a runaway
freight train for the Live Free or Die
State that's my litmus test I don't care
about we weren't as bad or whatever
no we decided we decided to have in our
state we we had a an executive brand
that picked the winners and the
losers and I will never forget
that state liquor stores you're all fine
essential small little mom and top pop
restaurant sorry shut it
down no I I there's no way I can ever
just forget any of
that having having a government decide
who was essential and who wasn't was out
of control and those are the things that
to me can never ever happen again so
whatever we all the different components
of the report that we provide here the
most important thing is to say we have
to follow the law our foundational law
our
constitutions we have to have people
that are
Ed that are that take their oath
seriously and and then don't uh that
don't um
overextend on people's rights no matter
emergency thank you representative Penza
for your opinion
um
and I think we need to you
[Music]
know I'm not going to say what you said
is wrong um but as represent LE has
pointed out the first few weeks we just
weren't sure um and the big question is
is who knew what
when and so to say that all decisions
were wrong I I would not want to go down
that road um because of if something in
the future uh that could be worse
um however I think finding out the data
of who knew what
when um is
important
and represent
Belia thank you bam chair and I'd just
like to to broaden our look a little bit
too because I know that the executive
branch catches a lot of flak and I I do
think some of that is
deserved but we need to look at all I
think everything that happened with all
the branches of government and I think
that really needs to include the fact
that we effectively shut down our court
system for the entire duration for
however a year and a half or more how
how much damage was done to our our
basic foundational system of justice
because we couldn't people didn't have
Speedy
trials uh the ability to bring lawsuits
for things was was
interrupted uh families needing to go to
Family Court to deal with their issues I
mean how I it it boggles my mind that
the that the pensioner who lost a lot
and it was struggling on social security
so they had to go get a job as a greeter
at Walmart or a bagger at Market Basket
is a Frontline employee and they can be
there doing their job during the
pandemic but we we don't have judges
seated at their bench because it's too
dangerous I that doesn't make a lot of
sense to me maybe maybe for the initial
brief per period sure I I can I was I
was a little panicked too I and I I'll
admit that I fell for some of the early
disinformation and I I was worried and I
was watching what happened I was like
okay two weeks I can do two weeks we'll
we'll kind of evaluate everything and
see where we're at um and then that was
extended and it was extended
again and the Judiciary remains shut
down the
executive um well the executive
certainly didn't shut down the executive
kicked in the hyper drive and and in
some ways came became three branches
into
itself and the
legislature um eventually got back into
you know it got back into session and
and did and did work although it was
interrupted to some degree um but I I
think as a part of our as a part of our
charge in investigating the covid
response we really need to dive into the
Judiciary a little bit and figure out
why did anybody believe it was necessary
to keep the Judiciary closed for that
length of time how many people may have
been impacted by not being able to get
trials in a speedy fashion as is their
constitutional right and everything else
that had to do with that and what just
what happened there
um all good points
um as you know this afternoon we'll have
um um commissioner Caswell in here
talking about the monies that were
received and how they were
dispensed um on May 31st director buckon
from Homeland Security was instrumental
in some of the guidance I believe uh
will be here to talk with us um we also
have
to understand that the executive branch
relies on the governmental agencies to
make their
decisions
um so if you're relying on your
governmental agencies and the
CDC and the federal government
guidance you better be able to trust the
people in your
state I'm just going to throw that out
there uh representative Penza and then
we will break for
lunch yeah I just would like to comment
on um what represent vure said yeah it
didn't fall in that one that was of
course
um what I was you know I was referencing
that but the same thing the shutting
down of the of the legislature as well
as
um oh my
gosh the
judicial we personally we had a a case
that was supposed to take place during
that time I just have to tell you how
difficult it is during Reg regular time
for anyone that is not fluent you have
to do every you can't talk to the courts
directly it's very hard to do that you
have to go through an 800 number they
have this whole
process and then you can't just walk
down and fill out paperwork it's
extremely hard they push you all
everything's online it's all through um
this New Hampshire court
system and not everyone is is computer
savvy like that it's it's not an easy
system to work and so you can just
imagine that's how it normally is right
now it was prior to um the pandemic and
it is currently like that so you can
just imagine there's no there's nobody
in the courts no one's and then you're
forcing people that don't are not fluid
with you know with working and filing
and having to attach documents and all
of that kind of stuff in an on online
system so you could just it's to me um
even worse but yeah it was I think it we
have to find that information out I
think that should all be on the record
as well representative Belcher that um
exactly how much time I believe it was
half how much Injustice was there for
all of those people is is mind-boggling
and just my little experience that I had
was um debilitating so I can't imagine
for serious situations whether it be
with with children involved in Family
Court I do have to say that when the
schools were shut down um and we weren't
we were living in Bedford at the time I
I talked to several Manchester School
teachers they were actually on their own
when kids wouldn't show up to class
online they were driving directly to
their homes because they were afraid for
their welfare so you can imagine not
having all of these things in place um
people took it on their own to do things
like that I can imagine how many stories
I would love to have people in the
committee that would talk to us about
stuff like that because they were scared
for the health and well-being of of
children that basically just fell off
times uh being almost noon time uh we're
going to recess until 1:00
um and
you
e
good afternoon everyone I just like to
take a set of recess and I'd like to
welcome representative uh wheeler uh and
please uh would' love to hear what you
say thank you madam chair members of the
covid efficacy response committee
response efficacy committee uh my name
is representative for the record Jonah o
Ryan
wheeler I'm here today uh because this
committee is handling the response to co
uh looking over what the state's
response was uh how it was handled how
it was handled with the citizens of the
state and I have uh my own personal
story
of
how the vaccine was handled in my case I
want to caveat by saying that I'm not a
scientist and I'm not uh an expert on on
vaccines or so you know I'm not going to
claim any expertise or make any claims
as to what happened to me but what I can
say is that I started
off a very Pro vaccine person I I grew
up in a in a household that uh wasn't
and went to public school and was told
that uh I was going to die because my
mom didn't give me vaccines that is what
I was told by my uh health teacher and
as a result I forced my mother to bring
me to the doctor and get my vaccines MMR
all these things that I hadn't gotten
before and that's fine you know nothing
as far as I know happened from
those during Co in 20120 it was a very
intense situation as we all
remember
um people were dying at
numbers that
[Music]
we hadn't seen I suppose and um there
was a lot of fear about what was going
on
um families were isolated I think of all
the people that were in hospitals dying
alone I think of all the people that
um had their lives stripped away from
them their work their livelihoods it was
an incredibly uncertain time we all know
that I mean it was
uh no matter what your opinion is it was
one of those things
that felt like anything could happen in
2021 it wasn't
until the fall of
2021 where I started to seriously
consider after having seen the roll out
and Etc uh getting my
vaccine and I was hesitant because
uh there was such a drum beat towards
everybody getting a shot that it made me
country's treatment
towards poor and low-income people with
the Tuskegee experiment where they
injected syphilis into black men without
their
consent for experimentation purposes or
other experiments done on the public by
the United States government or it's
Affiliates for experimentation on the
public I were those those are all public
record I was perfectly aware of those
and I was also concerned with the level
of control
that the people who are pushing these
vaccines fiser modna Johnson and Johnson
these pharmaceutical companies have uh
so much control in our federal
government that we know in the cases of
the opioid crisis where they told
doctors to push the uh opioids they knew
people would get addicted to onto the
citizenry or any of the other drugs that
have been involved in
the lawsuits that they've had to pay
billions they as an organiz uh as a
industry have had to pay billions to the
federal government and our taxpayers for
doing um billions of dollars in lawsuits
around drugs that have hopped clinical
trials drugs that have um been rushed
through the process and pushed as same
words that they use for the vaccine safe
and there were people in my life who
knew that I had an opinion about these
things I was concerned
about the what I just laid out the as
that be and how uh how they've
approached this somebody knew that I had
those concerns came to me and said well
you know throughout a whole conversation
we were having a conversation and I I
told them why I was feeling
hesitant and they brought back to me
after hearing my 10 minute long diet
tribe about well I'm worried about this
I'm worried about that I'm I'm I'm
hesitant because I'm looking at this
situation where I'm hearing these people
say one thing and then uh scientists and
the people in the journals notes say a
say a totally different thing the
vaccine stops transmission this was fall
of
2021 but we're finding out as the months
go on and fall 21 and then in the winter
that it actually did
not well it's actually because it's
going to stop your it's going to lower
your risk of
hospitalization well there's some
evidence contrary to that fact if you're
young if you're an older person there's
some evidence I that I've seen that
suggests that it would help you but if
you're a as I was at the time an
18-year-old with
no ill health effects with a perfectly
healthy
18-year-old it there is no evidence
necessarily that that risk is uh is
higher is what I was seeing at the time
and
the risk for myocarditis and pyio
carditis that was really a big worry of
mine as well I liked to run I liked to
be active I didn't want to have any
cardio problems I told this woman this
that we we were having a meeting at in
downtown petero I was telling her this
and she told me after hearing my
concerns well Joanie you have to make a
choice because you want to run for
office I know and you want to do this
and that and you have your job at uh the
or organization that I was working for
and you're going to have to make a
choice because people are going to find
out whether or not you're vaccinated so
you're going to have to get the vaccine
or not and tell people what your choice
is sitting there as an 18-year-old with
this older woman who I respected at the
time telling me that I had no I had to
make that op I had to make that decision
essentially right there right there then
as to whether or not to get that vaccine
late fall of
2021 um may I ask a question sure thank
you so was the condition of your
employment um to be vaccinated it was
heavily suggested that we get the vacine
thank you heavily
suggested not mandated but heavily
heavily
suggested it there was mandated via I
knew at the time I'm not going to be
able to go on business trips I'm not
going to be able to go to conferences
because at the time they were able to
say at these conferences you need to
have your vaccine shot and they showed
the card you needed to show the card Etc
so this is running through my mind as
she's saying you know you want to run
for office you want to have your job
here you either get the shot or you
don't but just so you know you have a
job you want to run for office be aware
what the consequences are essentially
saying if I don't get the shot then
you know just be aware that people will
know that and she'll make an effort to
tell people that I hadn't gotten the
shot so do you feel like that was a form
of Co coercion it was definitely a
threat it was definitely a threat of
some kind she wanted me to get that shot
it was bullying it was bullying that's
what it was and I sit there as an
18-year-old being you know this woman
that I respected and I go back to my
house and I'm I'm you know wallowing
about it I oh my gosh what am I going to
do a couple of weeks go by and it was
December of
2021 and finally after being just
disoriented I mean disoriented from the
news that was being pushed out
disoriented from this woman who kept
texting me did you get it yet oh here's
the van the van's coming through did you
get it yet you know and and making sure
that she texted a few other people to
make sure that they would text me she
texted a
uh African-American woman in town
who because she also had concerns and
was able to alleviate that woman's
concerns that woman had texted me
knowing that she could somehow see there
were a lot of people that uh a lot of
pressures that were put on me uh in that
four or so week period from having the
conversation with her
and represent Bel apologize for the
interruption I just wanted to ask a
quick question that's Sor actually two
quick questions uh so obviously a lot of
pressure around this to get the vaccine
I guess my my question would be on on
the whole totality of circumstances do
you feel
like mandates or uh strong
recommendations that were made by state
officials coming from within the state
or the federal government CDC um created
an environment where you felt like you
had to get it in order to move on with
the direction of your life that you
wanted to go in absolutely and that was
the big
Crux of the pressure am I going to be
able to uh if it's not running for the
state house and if I'm not successful in
that am I able to hold my job at this
nonprofit organization am I able to
continue to do the good work that I was
doing in the national public school
system am I able to go to college if I
wanted to after that no would be the
answer to that and follow in that's
exactly what I was interested in knowing
and if I may quick followup the second
the second thing I wanted to ask is now
you mentioned that um that this
particular person had reached out to
another African-American woman in your
town alleviated concerns they were also
interested in trying to get you to
become
vaccinated do you have any sense as to
whether this had anything to do with
what was colloquial known as vaccine
Equity e efforts at the time where there
was a a push even above and beyond the
general population and try to get any
minority population vaccinated because
they felt like they needed to increase
those numbers
I don't know if my case is exactly a
push in that way I know that that that a
woman had reached out to another black
woman because she knew that that was
going to be helpful for me specifically
but I do know what you're talking about
and I remember u in that summer and in
the summer afterwards hearing about well
how are we going to get the black people
vaccinated and hearing about watching
the video of Anthony fouchy and the
mayor of uh Washington DC walk through
the um poor areas of Washington DC the
more black and poor areas of Washington
DC and trying to get these people
vaccinated and there was a large push
around that but I forget if that was
exactly around the same time or I don't
think that had anything to do with M
thank you yeah and and and just to just
added the record we did have a vaccine
Equity program in New Hampshire where
there was a certain percentage of the
total the total vaccines that were
available set aside from the
general tranch only for minority
populations at that time thank you uh
excuse me uh represent beler if you can
get that dat room put in the records I'd
appreciate it we'll
do so it was December of 2021 and you
know all these you know sitting there
wallowing about all these pressures and
you know even my mother at the same time
was I might get it myself I had went to
her about this I might get it myself
because I I need to travel too and if I
have to go to Chicago or something like
that I might need it you know worried
about the idea that there might be some
requirement uh to get a vaccine to
travel
um and I it was a funny enough it was it
was a rainy day and I had just driven I
know I knew that there was some clinic
in a new ipswitch
and honestly all I can say is I was
disoriented and not making
uh I wasn't in the right decision
mindset I was thinking that my whole
life was uh based off of whether or not
I could get it I was thinking if somehow
I could get somebody you know I hate to
admit this on on the public record but I
think it was a consideration that a lot
of people made so I I'm going to include
it in the story but um there were people
that came to me who were so
antiva KN friends of mine that knew that
I was considering it and said no I'll
get you a fake vaccine card but you know
you hear about the fact that you're
going to be put in prison for having one
of those you know I don't know if that
was true or not but you I remember
seeing that on the news and thinking to
myself well I'm not getting put in
prison over over this um you know being
an 18-year-old who wasn't able to make
uh that proper decision on his own I
hopped in my car and I drove
to the clinic in newp switch and
um you know almost walked out but kept
in
line and I I got my shot and the woman
you know grabbed my arm and
she the VAC the administration of the
shot
was as far as I knew fine it was quick
but it was fine uh represent
Venza so we've had a lot of uh hearings
and especially for yesterday we've a lot
of discussion about um informed consent
and all of that so uh I assume you got
two shots probably one okay so you got
one um did you were you provided with
before that person um was it you know
was it a medical professional or no that
that she was a nurse practitioner if I'm
it was a it was through the manad
community hospital system yeah so were
you provided with like a you know like a
sheet that told you of all the
everything so so you weren't given any
information no no informed consent
document no informed consent document no
yeah thank you and
um you know she grabbed the arm
and gave me the shot told me to sit down
in the room that they had right there
and I sat down for 10 or so minutes just
to make sure that I wouldn't pass out I
suppose is what the procedure was and
then once I was able to I got up I asked
him if I could leave I left went into my
car went home uh threw up immediately
when I got home I don't know if it was
nerves or or what it was but that that
did happen and for about two months
afterwards it was fine I had no no
symptoms or anything like that I
actually had kind of forgotten that I
had gotten the shot first week I was all
oh my gosh about it but as soon as there
was nothing happening I was I I I my
concerns were alleviated I said to
myself all my hesitancy is fine I I
don't know what I was worrying
about then March of 2022 happened and um
I woke up one day with what I can only
describe as heart palpitations I woke up
uh with my heart with a irregular beat
um my chest was tight yeah sure oh yeah
yeah my chest was tight and uh you know
it was like feeling
sick hadada a and and everything that
lasted for about 3 hours and I went to
my mother and grandmother and I oh
you're just having a headache and I
figured the
same from that point on there was
numbness in my arm the left arm where I
had gotten it there was uh a pain in my
chest right here over my heart uh and it
would it was like e and flows it was um
some days it was a stinging like oh my
God this is really like uncomfortable
you know I have to adjust and you know
some days it was it was a light you know
Buzz
until the summer where it got really bad
I was running for election walking
around and you my office job became a
lot more active um so I was out and
about I was up I was doing things and
there were a number of times where and
mind you I was an active kid until I I
didn't have I wasn't sick didn't have
the flu since fourth grade when I got it
really bad and uh never had it since
perfectly healthy kid never had a one
problem what whatsoever other than a
stigmatism in my eyes and maybe some
migraines and here I am walking doors
and not able to make it two miles
without having to sit
down knowing I I can feel for myself I
knew my body I knew that my stamina had
gone down that my ability to stand up
and be up for a while had gone down that
my ability to be as active as I was had
gone down that my strength had gone down
that I was weaker than than I used to be
um I was eating just as much spinach as
I had when I was 17 years old I don't
know necessarily what had changed I had
a perfectly healthy diet I grew up with
a mother who apprenticed under Hoshi
Hayashi was a famous chef here in hker
you know I I grew up with great food and
it was well well ate I had good
nutrition good diet that hadn't changed
nothing about my life my diet anything
had changed other than the fact that I
had gotten the vaccine so when I'm
walking around here in the summer
Sweating Bullets like never before
unable to walk as I used to run as I
used to be active as I used to swim as I
used to bike as I used to feeling the
difference when I'm doing these things
in the summer feeling the difference
when I'm going around driving and I can
feel on my arm the numbness and I can
feel in my chest that slight pain and
thinking to myself
well what could this be what could this
be and and yes Madam chair I did think
maybe it's the vaccine I have no
evidence for this it is purely anecdotal
but given the fact that that is the only
thing in my life at that point that had
changed I that was was a consideration
of
mine that lasted up until about April of
2023 the shooting pain the numbness es
and flows and when the winter had
started up again and I had was less
active Fallen winter um it was not as
prevalent and actually had kind of
slipped my mind as we the craziness of
being a Freshman legislator came about
you know we get elected and we're swept
up in the orientation of it all and
getting your you know swept up in in
everything um I had forgotten about it
as a matter of fact sometimes there
would be a pain and I go o but you know
for the most part I'd forgotten about it
now did you ever go to the doctor uh for
this I did that's a good point actually
had forgotten about that in Fall of 2022
right before the election I had gone to
my primary care doctor about this
because it was really you know it this
was popping off as the election had
really heated up as we were really you
know large schedule at work it was
really just a busy season and I I think
part of that could have been stress
although I didn't feel too stressed out
that doesn't necessarily mean you
weren't stressed but I I didn't feel
stressed felt pretty calm I know what
stress is I've had
you know moments of stress very
stressful moments in my life before um I
went to my doctor about it he had said
oh maybe it's
stress being very dismissive I told him
the whole thing I said I'm getting pains
in my chest I have a numbness in my arm
I I you know and I
said look doctor I'm I'm not trying to
be an antivaxer here I I I got the shot
because I don't want to be an antivaxer
I had you know he was the same doctor
that had given me Shots before when I
had come
uh whatever that was like seventh grade
when I had you know forced my mom to
bring me to the VAC uh the doctor to get
some vaccines because I was all worried
about it uh he you know trying to tell
him I I am not an antivaxer here but
doctor when the only thing that has
changed in my life is the vaccine and
now here I
am passing out close to it on the side
of the road and Sharon walking in 75
degree heat not even that hot and
I used to be able to you know
Run Forever never stop you know perfect
endurance obviously a little bit of an
exaggeration but what's happening here
oh well you know I have one other kid
who's with me who might be going through
the same thing nothing to worry about
that's what I was told no followup no oh
we'll do this test or that test there
was just it's nothing to worry about
could be stress if it's not stressed
it's nothing to worry about about come
back if things get
worse I didn't know what to say I didn't
want to be you know forceful about it I
didn't want to
be I didn't know what to say I was a
19-year-old with no medical history and
no ability to question what uh this
doctor was saying to me right there
right then so I had left and didn't go
back so now we're here in April of 202 3
after forgetting about it after the
craziness of the session there was some
you know moments of numbness but it
mostly had gone away until I think it
was the third week in April of last year
and I was in the uh state house right
here outside of Room
101 uh this the senate committee room
right there talking to my chairman and
Chris Schultz and all three of us were
talking and I had woken up that day
actually I got to start with the with
how I woke up I woken up that day
feeling not great and it took me about
an extra 30 minutes to get out of get
out of the house but I did I you know
got out of the house drank my water ate
a banana or whatever I had that day and
got up and out of the house and the
feeling had gone away until it was you
know about 1:30 when I had been standing
there with my chairman and Chris Schultz
we were talking in the
hallway excuse me and out of nowhere I
get shooting pain in my chest my heart
gets tight is the only way I can
uh it was a very it was an incredibly
intense feeling of just you know it was
like a an instant flu like an
instant my my body went cold I I got
Shivers I started to cold sweat I my my
test was my chest was tight I
you know my first thought Madam chair
was I'm having a heart attack my second
thought was shut up you're 19 years old
you know you're probably you know
something this or that you know or I was
20 at the time
and all I could do was sit down at the
at the bench I didn't I didn't cause a
panic you know I was it hurt it did hurt
but I didn't want to cause a panic I
figured cuz I've had you know
migraines that have been pretty painful
before so it wasn't wasn't like a I felt
like maybe I'll pass out and then I'll
be fine that that's what it felt like it
felt like a nausea that wouldn't NE a
nausea that wouldn't result in a throw
up it it's a hard feeling to describe
it's really it was it was
uh trying to think about it now was it
it was scary
honestly I sit down and I didn't want to
cause alarm I sit down at the bench
right there Chris Schultz and the
chairman are still
talking I'm sitting there for what was
maybe five to 10 minutes of just me
listening to this conversation as I can
barely see my eyes have gone tunnel
vision I'm sitting there cold sweat in
pain I didn't know what to do I I really
kind of felt like I was dying and I just
sort of sat there in the in the in the
bench uh not wanting to cause alarm not
wanting to
just sort of sitting there with myself
in pain thinking
about
uh you know am I GNA die here in the
goddamn State House hallway like
geez and
um so after about 10 minutes or so the
feeling had kind of gone away I was just
praying as much as I could and I was
just praying to God I was just standing
I don't know I was thinking about a lot
of things in that 10 minutes but I was
listening to their conversation I was
trying to
just please Lord let this feeling go
away eventually the cold sweat had kind
of mitigated gone away you know
dissipated a little bit the nausea
feeling had gone away sufficient enough
to where I could walk into the anti room
of the State House I laid down there at
one of the benches of the anti room and
I sat there on my my computer for maybe
two hour two two hours two and a half
hours or so I I felt good enough to
stand up I felt good enough to walk so I
figured I'm fine and I sat there in the
anti room I didn't feel fine enough to
drive but I I sat there in the anti room
for a little bit did my work on the
computer until I did got in my car went
home didn't tell nobody or nothing about
it because I was worried I didn't want
to be
uh I didn't want to cause a l arm I
didn't want people to
say one thing or the other oh you're
just being young and crazy you you know
the hell is a 19-year-old having a an
attack like this I don't know if it was
a heart attack or not I don't know what
happened but what the hell is a
19-year-old having
a something like that happen you know
and I told one person about it some a
colleague of mine here and their
immediate response was I was a panic
attack it was
stress and I said to them well I feel
like I would have to have been panicked
or stressed for that thing to have been
a panic attack or a stress attack and I
know what a panic or stress attack is
and I wasn't panicked or stressed I was
perfectly calm and content in fact I was
just trying to think about my own
mortality as a 19-year-old and Ponder
the life in which I lived and how it
ended here in the State House
hallway I wasn't panicked at all I was
just amazed at that that was that was
the culmination of of n of 20
years and
um so I continued to not tell people
about it because that was someone's in
initial reaction I told that person
maybe two days after it had happened I
told my mom maybe two weeks after it
happened I told my grandmother I I know
they were like oh you should go to the
doctor and say something about it to
them I did they dismissed it again as I
saw well I will but I I'm pretty sure
they're going to dismiss it I did they
dismissed it Panic or stress attack they
said don't worry about it
and
just not knowing you really well but
seeing you around the state
house you do not look like someone who
panics or stresses very easily you are
to me a very calm and
even individual I appreciate that
representative kto I I would agree with
that I I think I am you know I'm a
meditator I I I'm a breather you know I
I think I am pretty calm especially with
some some of the things that happened I
could be a lot less calm that's for sure
represent a
Penza so I just want to time frame wise
I kind of want to place this so um so
the shot
was like end of December right December
of 21 21 y so shop was end of December
21 and then they started like end of
February or or March or something like
that a couple months after you said I
had the shot on December 21 there was a
year of the 2022 year was the numbness
and the pain in the chest and then in
2023 April of 23 that was when that
event had happened okay in the doctor
piece because I think that that's
probably the most important out of this
whole conversation so when you went to
the doctor which was not even
not even a year it would have been in
the fall it it would have been maybe
seven months seven or eight months seven
months so that was and you went and you
you know whatever brushed it off now the
second
time I don't even want to excuse the
first time but the second time if this
was a a practitioner just a regular
general practitioner immediately that
should have been a flag to bring you
into a cardiologist point so there was
no mention of that you should have had
scin hands you should have had all of
that at that point especially if you
were I I believe you probably had a
minor um heart attack so and there was
no mention of tests there was no mention
of followup it was you probably had a
it and uh you know luckily I think that
I don't know
what I feel much better after that it
happened in April of 23 and the summer
of 2023 was was fine and the numbness
still exists but
it's way less you know sometimes when
I'm thinking about it like before I came
here before I'm about to tell this story
I'm thinking about it so on the way up
here I was like thinking about and you
know I could feel it in my arm but ever
since then it's been decently all right
there's been some moments where I if I
really really work myself where I can
I'm oh I got to sit down and I I I don't
have my strength as I used to I don't
you know that's still the same but um
you know the reason I wanted to tell
this story I had I watch most of the
committee I watch almost every Committee
hearing I can uh here in the legislature
I I try to be as active as I can and I
saw this was happening I knew that from
conversations with the you
representative comto that this happening
and unfortunately I wasn't able to be on
the committee uh for one reason or the
other but we'll leave that for another
day
and but I knew there are people Madame
chair
throughout this state that went through
the same thing that I did but have no
voice to be able to tell their story to
them it probably was a panic or a stress
attack because they have no Outlet to be
able to know that there might
be some myocardial effect
to your shot or to something else
environmentally and Madam chair I am
deeply concerned when anecdotal in my
life I know that there are so many young
people that have gone
through heart or brain or some kind of
blood vessel syndrome I don't know if
that's the right
term and we hear this anecdotally across
the country as
well I as a representative would be
remiss and feel bad with myself if I
didn't at least come and tell this story
uh these stories should be told told
people should feel open to tell their
stories this isn't
about it's so unfortunate to me that
this has become a partisan thing because
this isn't about one party or the other
this isn't about pushing a narrative or
the other this is about people in our
state who have gone through incredibly
tough experiences by
themselves isolated with the medical
profession telling them it's a panic or
stress attack
or attributing it to something else if
it's a more extreme case and then
getting him on this line of of a a wild
goose chase that isn't actually finding
what the symptoms are again I'm not a
scientist I'm not a vaccinologist I
don't I don't know if it was the vaccine
I have my hunches I have my I have my
assumptions what I do and I and I I I
can't you you know I can't make a
recommendation beyond what I know but
but what I do know is that people were
forced into this people were forced into
getting a vaccine that they were
hesitant to get and after getting that
vaccine they went through health effects
that they they they hadn't gone through
before that alone that correlation which
is not causation but that correlation
alone is enough to worry me as uh as an
individual who I think is pretty
levelheaded and clear-minded and and I
think it's worrying a lot of people
throughout our state people who were
fully uh you know I fully a part of they
they believed it fully and and I think
they they too are worried because of the
effects that that people have had here
so that's that's why I wanted to tell my
story Madam chair and and I you know
it's not to for one conclusion or the
other but it's to bring a story that I
know other people in our state have
faced because I've talked to those
people and I know that those people uh
feel isolated because there's no voice
in government or the medical profession
that's that's trying to truly listen to
them and look at their case and and see
where they're moving forward so
hopefully through committees like this
and through uh research that's happening
across this country we can get that done
um if you don't mind um uh couple things
is when you we started out when you
started out the conversation you
mentioned that you were concerned about
myotis and some other issues prior to
actually taking the
vaccine um how did you obtain that
knowledge because it wasn't necessarily
readily
available well I there were people
um you know I followed this guy online
you know it's always interesting when
you say oh I followed a guy online but
there was a man who posted YouTube
videos uh named I think this is the
first place that I had seen it um named
Dr John Campbell who had started out um
recommend part of the reason I took the
vaccine is because he recommended and he
too had got I think he had gotten up to
three or four shots
um but he had pointed out that there was
definitely cuz he was trying to respond
and debunk the antia conspiracy side of
it he has since moved to uh apologize
for some of his behavior in the first
two years which is kind it's kind of an
interesting uh timeline to watch but
during the fall of 21 he was I think
that was the first person who I had
heard bring up that there was
some higher risk of
myocarditis
um or inflammation of the heart after
taking the vaccine but he had said the
first per but him being the first person
who had brought that up had said
afterwards that there is uh higher risk
of
myocarditis from getting covid and that
was the the jumby that you heard uh from
most people during that time um now I
believe we're still saying that it is
safe and effective um for
children um do you think that that is
proper
labeling I I couldn't say I couldn't say
I
um yeah I have my personal opinions that
I I don't know if a 5-year-old needs the
coronavirus shot is what I would say but
I I can't make a medical recommendation
for parents um and one final question
from um now you said you were an avid
Runner and very active um can you still
do those activ
activities not like I used to I I I you
know I tried a bike last summer and I
tried to uh I did get out um didn't swim
as much as I wanted to last summer but
you know like I said it is significantly
harder for me to get out and do those
things
um it's I I find it easy to walk
nowadays it there was a period in 2022
when it was really kind of difficult to
walk around um doing door knocking and
stuff like that it's easier to walk um
and I'm sure as life goes on you know
body is a powerful powerful thing and
and there's uh you know sure I'll heel
young lucky on that end but uh no it is
not the same to to go Bike and Hike and
swim it's a there's a significant and
noticeable stamina difference in
endurance
have thank you madam shair have you
thought
of going and getting
uh the diagnosis like seeing um a heart
specialist to get a diagnosis of whether
I
mean it's it's very documented you fall
within that range you're a young male it
I mean there the increase um there's
many different studies that talk about
this and it's not just myocarditis it's
it's paric carditis it's you know
several different things so um a heart
specialist to to get that diagnosis and
just to see to monitor that uh you know
I after I went to my primary care
specialist the second time after what
had happened in April of 23 and he had
told me that I got a had a a panic
attack I I actually initially believed
him you know I really just wanted to
believe that um
uh it was a panic attack even though I
didn't panic and I wasn't stressed um it
wasn't until I talked to my grandmother
again and told her what he had said that
she was no I I don't think so and I and
I agreed you know I didn't want to
believe that that was the truth I didn't
because it wasn't I didn't Panic or
stress but
um I didn't follow up after it because
he he had just dismissed it and um was
just sort of well maybe I'm maybe I'm
being crazy I guess maybe maybe it
wasn't as intense as it was I don't know
it was you just keep you go through
those things you know as time goes on
you know and as life progresses it's oh
I guess it wasn't as intense as it was
it wasn't you know there's no need to
what is this you know I'm fine I'm still
here so I just
didn't uh I didn't follow up with a
specialist after he didn't move to test
move to do anything other than say he
probably had a panic
thank you madam
chair I appreciate that testimony thank
you and I and I know what that feels
like too because I was in that same
position after getting the vaccine what
I would like to do is I'd like to tell
you a few things that we have heard um
in our committee about uh vaccine safety
and efficacy and then give you a chance
to respond to see what you think about
this so we've heard
that and this is from federal government
data that the CDC proposed a method of
evaluating safety signal coming from the
vaccines before they were rolled out and
they established okay this number this
number this number this number we're
going to look for this and if it exceeds
these certain thresholds that's a safety
signal we got a problem if it exceeds
those thresholds and we know we now know
that those safety thresholds were
exceeded for multiple conditions within
a period of months of the vaccine being
rolled out we know that by November of
2020 when they were designing the vsafe
vaccine safety data system they had a
laundry list of known side effects from
the vaccines that included myocarditis
paric carditis autoimmune disorders and
neurological
disorders we know from this further in
this data the vsafe data which is the
best data we have this is federal data
from the CDC
that in excess of 7% of patients
receiving the vaccine had serious
adverse reactions to the
vaccine more than uh more than 25% had
to miss work or school so
that's way more than that that's a big
number but 7even plus perent serious
adverse reactions by the way serious
adverse reactions those are defined as
big things
like
myocarditis like death
like permanent
disability brain damage lots of things
serious Adverse Events more than
7% and we knew that
and they knew that before you received
your
respond well you know those numbers are
true that is that's a very that's a very
sad State of Affairs
that there should be a space open for
people to tell their story like this so
that we can have solid data about how
many injuries were taking place we know
that V's the vaccine injur most people
don't know that exists um and the people
that do know that
exists don't always report we need to
make sure that that system is
strengthened so that people have an
ability to report their vaccine
injuries
and what I can say representative beler
you know
the you know we try to operate in good
faith here in this legislature so what
I'll do is say the best faith what I
think happened is they there was a a
novel uh virus that came from China and
we we didn't know how to handle it and
we rush through with billions of dollars
and very little safety trial um a
vaccine based off of
uh
uh a technology that yes has existed for
the last 20 years but um had not been
used in the general population until
this situation and I think that there
were and this is best face you know
assuming that the pharmaceutical
companies were operating in be fa best
faith
um they rushed through this process and
a lot of people were hurt as a
result that's that's what I think
happened I think a lot of
people were bullied into getting it
because there was an assumption
that everyone getting it
would save us from this novel virus that
assumption didn't end up being true and
I I think people are going to have to I
think we need solid data so we can have
a a
solid response to what happened here I
you know I think that's the benefit of
hopefully work that can be done in
committees like
this um yesterday we learned and I don't
know if you're aware and and maybe if I
misspeak uh I'm sure one of the
committee members will correct me um but
AC as vs
goes the only person that has to report
to theirs is the person who injected you
if you got injected and then went to
your doctor there is no responsibility
for them because they didn't do the
injection um is uh representative
Penza yeah what um thank you madam chair
what representative um kto just said is
actually true um and and kind of to
expand that a little bit more more
is the there there's no real training so
I mean we couldn't even put a percentage
but it is extremely low so right now if
you look at
1% of people you know it's it it's
possibly only 1% that of people that
report to a theirs um practitioners
aren't taught this um nurses aren't
taught this and so that's the problem it
is a very difficult cumbersome system so
if you wanted to try to go in there and
Report something it like you said it's
almost near impossible but based
upon if you suffered something and we
know this from another person that came
to testify what they had to go through
to get it reported their daughter's
injury from a a I believe it was the J&J
correct
I'm not sure which one but it was she
had it done at a hospital correct so um
but for that family to be able to get
that reported and reported correctly was
an unbelievable process um the first
report was wrong and inaccurate so so
just to understand it's it's it's not
the greatest thing that we heard
yesterday and you know I I'll push it
off to representative belard that he can
explain is the gentleman that was able
to get this information from bsafe and
you know if you had signed up for that
you know it was this app and they
thought they were going to get all this
great data they had 10 million people
sign up for this now not everybody
necessarily was in there and and
reported all of it but they got an
unbelievable amount of data way more
than we could ever get from because
these people they were all on board
they're like yes I'm getting my shot D
so it's totally different and opposite
than than a system and they had
open um besides radio buttons on there
that you could select they had open
areas where you could write about 250
characters so they're just getting that
some of that data now they're going to
get all of that and I guess that is
quite damaging one one woman for example
in every single place she could write
was in who was injured please help me
me and it nobody
Pa thank you Madame chair
so um three parts first part um more
like responding my understanding there
are several ways that information is
aggregated so obviously we safe with one
separate Silo with about 10 million
participants that was just
uh rolled out during uh the co response
so then then we have uh wir database
cdc's vaccine adverse uh reactions
database uh and uh there are some other
siles that collect that data and uh I
think we might need
to check with somebody who knows how it
work my understanding is like
yes person who administered vaccine if
he knows about an adverse side effect
it's that person responsibility
to uh to report it to the virus database
but my understanding is as people can uh
as medical professionals and even
patient I believe can self report to
virus database and as anecdote uh I I I
know
that a couple of other representatives
from both parties they actually admitted
of having uh uh adverse reactions to uh
to covid vaccine and making sure that
the report made it to the virus database
so one of my questions to Jonah would be
would you consider to try and uh see if
you can self-report your experience uh
uh to the CDC official uh database virus
absolutely absolutely and and as a
followup uh like I understand your
concern that you are not a medical
professional and you're not a scientist
and the fact that uh you had problems
came after vaccine you cannot still
definitively that it was caused by
vaccine but people who created virus
database they understand it they
understand that those reported reactions
they don't
always uh from uh for example from legal
point
Cause prove the causality and it's one
of the reasons why in uh in official
databases we have only one person under
18 from New Hampshire who died from
covid officially but four people who are
dead
with uh side effects after covid vaccine
so why nobody car so one of the reason
is like they say yeah those four kids
are there they reported to CDC virus
database as New Hampshire kids who died
after receiving covid-19 vaccine but uh
it's not necessarily caused by vaccine
even though
so so yeah yeah I encourage you uh to
self report and also like previous
people said if there any way
to to get some uh additional monitoring
on your health uh it would be maybe it
will make sense thank you represent
beler thank you madam
chair uh representative wheeler you
offered a very very generous
interpretation of
uh what occurred and I appreciate that I
I do and certainly we can't say with any
definitive
um
finality exactly what occurred I do just
want to remind uh the committee and I
I've previously read this into the
record so we've already are in
possession of this uh through a Freedom
of Information Act we became well not us
but another party who we then got it
from came into possession of emails uh
internal emails within the Food and Drug
Administration the
FDA um documenting that early on when
they became aware of the death of two
young men from myocarditis in the
aftermath of uh Co
injection they were very very worried
very
concerned um not about the the deaths
but about how that knowledge would
population yeah I've heard similar
stories about uh what had happened in
the FDA and CDC when they had seen
stories that they labeled as
misinformation come out into the
populace and how they were worried that
that was going to seep down to the
vaccine Equity program with uh black and
lowincome black and brown low income
communities in the country that were
already hesitant seeing stories like
that and increasing that hesitancy
because of the stories that
they and I know that a lot of those
stories were wiped from the internet as
well as a
Penza I just like to follow up to in
kind of like a did you know um piece
because we we learned this yesterday and
just we learned so many things but this
is one that is um is so important and it
just looks at you know it's not just our
state but it's our entire country and
how we're different than other countries
and
um because we don't
have we because in 1986 we gave full
immunity from any sort of liability to
pharmaceutical companies for their
products for their vaccines or emergency
youth authorizations fall under the prep
act and completely immun U full immunity
there from liability um
we're just we're sitting ducks in a
sense because of that you can't go after
the people that have injured you and how
it's set up with this uh it's kind of
like this vaccine Court there's
limitations there I think he said for
death it's like 250,000 it's it's
unbelievable and it's very hard and
there's time limitations and all of this
kind of stuff um in other
countries how things are reported it's
like in a think of it like a central
system it's all coming one place like
for example if if the FDA is supposed to
be the monitoring whatever arm like all
the data would be filling through there
right you wouldn't have okay well you
self-report here a position puts it in
here everybody would know right you're
all putting that data especially if
you're talking about with this millions
of injections happening with under
emergency youth authorization that it
would make sense so that's why other
data coming in from other countries um
like there was a Danish study that's
that's Crystal Clear is
because the centralized way that they've
handled this makes sense so in all
actuality let's just use fizer as an
example if you took a fiser shot and you
had a reaction you could if you signed
up for vsafe you could have put
something in there you could possibly
get your information into vs you could
call a 1 1800 number that is listed on
the CDC FDA site and then also fizer had
a way that you could report to them as
well now the worst thing about it is is
none of this data that's not all the
same it's all different models and this
and that and some very convoluted some
not even asking the correct information
or even providing uh the correct radio
buttons about what you're experiencing
so you couldn't you can't really have
like this wealth of
knowledge and I don't know if you
realize that that we're really the the
only country that is so
broken with that well I did realize that
we're the only country that props up the
pharmaceutical lobby as much as we do
we're the only country that allows uh I
think we're the only country other than
maybe an island nation that allows
pharmaceutical advertising on television
in the way that we do um there's a few
things that we do with pharmaceutical
drugs and allowing the companies to do
things that uh hop over safety hop over
obstacles that exist in other country to
make sure that the drugs and products
that they're putting out are safe um we
kind of have a free-for-all here uh in
the United States of America with
pharmaceutical companies with uh
large oil companies with chemical
companies I mean there is a lot of
free-for-all happening here in the
United States and um and we see that
happen well in conclusion
off uh would you believe that
uh uh when uh government gives uh uh leg
immunity to manufacturers of vaccines
and then to specifically of covid vaccin
they also set up injury compensation
funds uh and that uh even those funds
are small but uh still there were
probably a couple of thousand dollars
for a person so by by dismissing
your symptoms uh
that medical professional in your town
and by not informing you about that
Federal injury Compensation Program
youve
intially
denied uh filing in the the uh allowed
window to get those few thousands
dollars of
compensation that I believe you were
entitled well I think there's a lot of
people that were entitled to that money
that weren't weren't told about it if
that's
true
terrible I yes in conclusion Madam chair
I just wanted to say you know thank you
for opening up the space for me to tell
my story you know I
was going back and forth as whether or
not I necessarily wanted to you know
because I can't say whether or not uh it
was the vaccine that caused what
happened to me on April of 2023
what I can say was is I was and am a
healthy was a 21 20-year-old kid who uh
was very active up
until December of 2021 when I had gotten
the one shot of the fiser vaccine and
since then have had reduction in stamina
a numb arm tight chest culminating in
what happened in April of 2023 with
with um with what I've been told as a
panic attack so um thank you for opening
up the space for me to say this here
because I have met a lot of people
across the state who have gone through a
similar
experience never talking about their
experience outside of their family or
their friends um because they're worried
about backlash people don't want to be
labeled an antivaxer they don't want to
be labeled anti-id they don't want to be
labeled a conspiracy theorist
um I I don't want to be labeled those
things either you know I want to be
compliant with the society in which we
live to an extent and I want there to
be safe vaccines out there I believe in
the science that has created these
beautiful medical devices that we live
off of today I want those to be safe and
effective in a true sense I want the
pharmaceutical companies to be held to
account and and I want them to
be putting out safe and effective
pharmaceutical products
um I mean ex like like I said before I I
don't think it's too much of a leap to
believe the pharmaceutical companies
that pushed the opioids onto our country
or any of the ineffective and dangerous
drugs that they've pushed onto our
country I don't I don't think it's too
far to believe that they they might have
uh jumped a few obstacles that should
have been walked around I suppose so I'm
going to put that and in the end hurt a
few thousand people in this country we
don't know how many because there isn't
the appropriate data but I hope
committees like these through a measured
and balanced and appropriate approach
can hopefully find some some truth
through this so that we don't have to
have such a partisan ranker debate about
measured it's just you know people
deserve to be heard when they are when
they're hurt has nothing to do with
whether or not it's a vaccine it's just
we should find out what is causing all
these very young people to to be very uh
injured so thank you madam chairman and
I appreciate the the opportunity to come
speak here today and the invitation
thank you thank you very much for coming
and uh sharing your story I appreciate
it
Caswell I would like to thank you for
making the time to be here today I know
you have a very busy schedule so thank
you so much I'm happy to be here today
um I received the information that that
wanted to talk about today so let me
pull that a little closer um I thought
maybe what I might do is just sort of
give a little background on gopher and
sort of what all that's about and first
of all I would start by saying I
apologize for the acronym I didn't come
up with the acronym gopher but it is
what it is it's the governor's office
for emergency relief and Recovery uh
that office was established by an
executive order right at the beginning
of covid in April of 2020 um during a
period of time uh would say for the next
two years uh gopher was pretty much
engaged in the um in the management of
the funds that came from the cares act
uh and the way that we did that at the
time was uh we had an assembly of I
would say about 10 or 15 state employees
from other agencies that were assigned
to work uh undergo for for a period of
time so we had people that um policy
people we had uh
administrative and accounting
individuals some legal people and some
um Outreach people and that is pretty
much how gopher operated in those we
call I call it the early days of gopher
um when the arpa uh was passed the
American Rescue plan that was passed uh
by Congress in early
2021 um gopher um was assigned basically
to to take over over the the continue
the same kind of operation that we were
doing under cares act for um for those
funds and it's important to to know that
under arpa there were many many buckets
of funds one of the largest was called
the state and local fiscal Recovery Fund
that was the most flexible of those
funds and that were those were the funds
that goer was assigned to uh to manage
on behalf of the state um and so uh that
is pretty much where we have been
operating since
then um and I can talk a little bit
about kind of that process and so on um
but what gopher has been specifically
tested with and I think on a day-to-day
basis is I mentioned is to just manage
the overall um um uh use and delineation
and deployment of those funds uh we work
with all the state agencies we work with
the legislature we work with different
grantees
uh we perform eligibility analysis so
each of these particularly under under
arpa each of these programs have
specific requirements and they have to
go into specific expenditure categories
and we have to be able to account for
all of that going forward in our regular
reporting to the federal government and
and to the public um we have uh
different types of structures for
different types of programs and
different grants and some are some are
uh some are structured differently than
others uh depending on the
situation um we have a very substantive
website where all of our uh all of the
programs and the funds and who they've
gone to Are all uh made available um on
our public website so transparency is
obviously something that we spend a lot
of time on um and going forward uh we're
working really sort of and I think um
moving toward a scenario where a lot
more of the operations that we are
engaged in are in compliance and
Regulatory Compliance and reporting to
all the various uh agencies on uh what
the how the funds have been used and how
they're going so um in terms of the
total amounts like the big picture
amounts under cares act the state was uh
was allocated $1.25
billion uh and so that was the first
iteration of that uh we received those
funds on April 17th of 2020
uh the funds ultimately needed to be uh
obligated by the end of
2021 with full expenditures completed by
September 30th 2022 all of that has
occurred those funds all yes ma'am
representen thank you madam chair I
really want to listen to your testimony
but I have to I have to go home but I
have a just a quick question and it's
about time frame so I know you were
explaining it which is good um so I know
when everything started I I kind of
follow that very closely with gopher
actually a couple representatives from
straford County just met with you
recently yes okay so I'm kind of part of
that piece too um I didn't understand
how gopher kind of transitioned into
arpa so thank you for that explanation I
know it's probably a lot more um a lot
more weeds to it than what you explained
so in a sense can can I just understand
when how long will it go for right so
that's what I want to try okay so I
understand with a federal government I
know certain things have all based upon
time and then um and things run out and
then it's gone if it's not spent it's
gone or not accepted but is there is
there an end in sight because I know
certain things like you just said had an
end in sight but now with arpa kind of
where does that if you can explain that
I sure hope there's an end in sight I'm
really looking for it but I would say so
to answer your question um arpa right
now we are required to have all
obligations complete by the end of this
calendar year so any of the decisions on
what is going to be uh be receiving
funding under the again under the sfrf
the state and local fiscal Recovery Fund
sorry for the acronyms the sfrf
programming has to be obligated by the
end of this calendar year uh then there
is a period of an additional two years
to complete all the expenditures so
everything that is obligated by the end
of this year has to be spent by the end
of
2026 so that's the basic overview of it
there's not a lot of wiggle room there
but what I was about to say is under
car's act originally That was supposed
to be the end of 2020 2020 and uh on
three days before that deadline Congress
extended it for a year
so there's stories to go with
that there might be a little end of the
tunnel light for you in 2026 who knows
yes that's right uh we're looking
forward to that but yeah I think and and
the last thing I would say
representative that related to this is
that at this point the state has
allocated the entire amount that we have
under sfrf it that doesn't mean that
it's been fully obligated and I'm sorry
for the different the different terms
but by obligated what we're talking
about is that funding is under contract
so there are still some allocations that
gopher has made to State agencies for
example and they have not yet been able
to secure a contract to to to spend
those funds they need to have that done
by the end of this year so um you've
probably seen and heard that we've been
doing some reallocations of funds these
are programs that we could identify
we're not going to fully spend what
their allocation was and so rather than
send that money back to the federal
government we want to make sure that we
have as as much of that uh amount that
we have under sfrf fully obligated by
the end of this calendar year so it's
going to be kind of this process over
the next couple of months to make sure
you and feel free to reach out to me
anytime if there's other questions that
you you that you have on all of this
kind of thing I know it's something
you're
following so just again just to go back
to just a few notes that I made here the
the the total amount for the arpa sfrf
funding that we received uh that the
state received is n 99
4,555
um can we just say shy of 1 billion yeah
that's what I always say but I know you
guys like to be exact so it's $994,000
7760 yeah I mean we're holding back to
60 cents just for entertainment value
but um the uh those funds were received
in two tranches uh one on May 19th 2021
and then a second trunch I think of
equal amount on uh the same date in 2022
and as we just spoke those are the uh
deadlines and obligations uh that we
have to for spending and and using that
money so the last thing that I'll say
and then we can talk about whatever you
want the um our focus on these funds has
been to make investments in capital
Capital Investments we have tried very
hard to avoid uh making Investments that
are going to have long-term
administrative and operational cost
implications for state government or
really for anybody else uh that was uh
we call it the prime directive from the
governor and I think we've done a pretty
good job at um at really implementing
that and in fact uh there was recently a
study from the Pew charitable trust that
gave New Hampshire a very high number I
think it was close to 80% of the funds
and according to their
uh their uh analysis that we had put uh
into those Capital sort of I don't want
to call them infrastructure because they
weren't all infrastructure but Capital
Investments um so good examples of that
would be we've put a significant amount
of money into water and sewer uh funds
and uh programs uh through Department of
Environmental Services uh we have
invested uh a little over hundred
million of arpa funds for affordable
housing and for uh municipalities um uh
to to move forward how they wish on
affordable housing initiatives we
continued to have some uh early earlier
in this um uh dur in this period you
know still into 2021 we were still able
to use the arpa funds to help with some
of the immediate covid responses that
were still going on at that time um and
we also have seen a pretty significant
investment into um mental and Behavioral
Health Systems um and and really uh in a
sub use disorder uh context as well
because those numbers skyrocketed as I'm
sure you're aware during covid so arpa
funds were used for en large for um for
those types of
services um a quick step back to car's
act which was different in some ways I
would say that a majority of the funds
that we used under car's act were used
to stabilize the really the private
sector uh at that time we put a
significant amount of resource into to
the Main Street Relief Fund uh into a
program for self-employed individuals
which was aptly named self like don't
ask me to tell you what it stood for I
don't remember but the uh self-employed
livelihood fund thank you Chase um uh
see that's why I brought him he's good
with the acronyms but uh and then we had
another program the nonprofit Enterprise
Relief Fund Nerf so we gave a good
amount of resources to nonprofit
employers so all all together I think
that total I would say somewhere between
75 and 80% of the funds and um and we
did that very quickly we we moved those
funds um as I said we received those in
April of 2020 we had that first Main
Street Relief Fund online by June of
that year and and I and I like to think
that that made a difference in terms of
our ability to rebound quickly a lot of
other states were just starting to think
about what they were going to do with it
by the time we were operating uh
programs um so the other thing we did do
uh under cares Act was as you'll recall
also there was uh there was a lot of uh
there there were a lot of issues with um
assisted living facilities nursing homes
and other locations where uh they were
having difficulty with Staffing and
other things and costs um that were
escalating we did uh dedicated uh some
resources to stabilizing those
organizations at that time um um and
then really the last one that in terms
of big and we did a lot of programming
but I think in terms of big Investments
was in the agriculture space um a lot of
our agriculture uh communities were also
very heavily damaged by not being able
to get their um their their Pro their
produce and their products um to Market
or sold so th that's kind of the big
overview I know there's there's a whole
lot I mean this has been about four
years that we've been in operation um
that I'm happy to talk about but that's
that's the extent of it for at least my
statement represent
Vel thank you for coming sir it's good
to see you on a uh Friday
afternoon
um so just in the uh original um
creation of
gopher there was originally some sort of
a commission or something I I because I
remember listening remember Homeland sec
was running the uh the
phones the days before we discovered the
magic of zoom and team heard of Zo we
were having like you know 4our
conference calls um yes you're correct
there was the legislative Advisory Board
uh which was part of the uh under cares
act that was a group obviously that we
kept up to date and informed with regard
to uh how the funds were being uh
deployed there was also as I recall a
stakeholder Advisory Board the component
under car's act um concurrent to all of
that and you might also remember
representative is the was the U
reopening task force that also had those
God aul long um conference meetings over
phone um but those were also quite
informative to the work of goer and I
know that was sort of in my Bea
existence which was you know to try to
understand from businesses what they
were facing at the time with the regard
to closures and what was closed and what
was opening and why and balancing that
with public health uh in our Public
Health division um that was also I would
say um an informative component of the
time followup
um because I just remember there was
discussion at that point whether the
fiscal committee was going to have
authority of the oversight of the funds
and then I guess a determination was
made to leave it to to the Gopher um
oversight so yeah so well first of all
under cares act remember we were in
state of emergency so that was a
different animal and then um when we got
to arpa yes I think the decision the
discussion and the decision was that
gopher was already in a position of
having all of the Personnel to manage
these types of Grants and programs but
given that we were no longer in state of
emergency we that's when sort of the the
the role of fiscal committee came back
into the picture and they've been in it
ever since okay that's what I wondered
because um you know we're in the with
the budget process and all that
everybody is really getting um ecstatic
about arpa opportunities to fund uh
these different uh
appropriation uh bills and I knew at
some point that that fiscal had so they
basically have control of of how the
funds for arpa are disseminated well
they have they yeah they ultimately have
to approve any of the expenditures that
have been proposed so um we were just
there today with with a with a with with
another tranch of programs and and
funding initiatives that they reviewed
and
approved I have some others but other
people can talk oh follow up yeah I mean
I guess the other thing is just based on
the charge of this committee
which is to to kind of look into the
response of the State uh from a efficacy
standpoint in
covid I was sort of listening to what
you were describing and I of how the
funds were used especially the car's act
and I was trying to understand how much
of this money was used for like vaccines
or health health related issues I heard
you say about the nursing homes and
stabilizing that Workforce situation but
how much of it was actually used by the
public health sector would you say a lot
a lot of the cares act fund uh in
particular and I'm sorry I don't have
the exact numbers I couldn't possibly
bring everything to be able to answer
that type of question but we can give
you a full list of everything that I
mean and it's available on our website
as well but I mean if you wanted
something uh in writing we can give you
um a list of the
under any category you would like if
you'd like to have the covid response I
do recall there were a number of
instances where car's act funds were
used for uh direct covid response um and
whether that was those early
um I don't even remember a lot of it is
those anyway so there there were a lot
of a lot of funds that were used under
car's act for that and I would say the
the other thing is is regard to how the
how we differentiate or how I have
always differentiated the the the two
programs cares and arpa Caris was really
an emergency response initiative those
were funds that were used uh to directly
respond to at the time what we didn't
really know much about and what we were
uh we were almost in a constant
Balancing Act of issues that were
affecting the economy and issues that
were affecting Public Health and we had
one pot of resource to try to manage
those those challenges the arpa funds
have been uh I think are I qualify as
being more in terms of response so you
know we've been through sort of the deep
dark days of covid and now we have these
other resources to Aid the recovery that
that that happened as a result so most
in a lot of cases those are um
investments in like I was talking about
in investments in infrastructure and
organizations and programs
that um origin originated in some way at
least to the the the impact of the co
pandemic well are you working with
Homeland Security in their sort of after
action yes report because I I think all
of us would hate for you to have to uh
do duplicative work but um I think it
would be interesting as part of our
charge since you have a better handle on
health related expenditures of car money
than we do that maybe you could do some
sort of helpful snapshot yes I would be
happy to do that for you so for health
related expenditures under car's
act I mean we can we can look at the at
the mission statement one more time but
um our charge isn't really as broad as
others I mean I think one thing you're
interested in too is education and what
sort of Education supports
there might have been I let me get that
one to you I'm not I don't I can't
possibly remember every program that we
did but I would be happy to so education
Healthcare under carees act yeah I mean
it sounds to me like yeah it could be
arpa but it sounds to me that if we're
looking at the efficacy of our covid
response it sounds to me correct me if
I'm wrong that what you're talking about
is more the emphasis during the
emergency with cares focused yeah I and
in regard to that I would say probably
the big buckets you should consider
looking at would be the economic impacts
the public health impacts and the
infrastructure impacts I think those
would be the big three
categories um but that's not there are
others but I think you could probably
get most of them into those three
categories I mean our charge is I would
say more Health focused than I see okay
yeah and because I mean we also don't
want to do well for Education right I
don't think we want to do the Homeland
Securities work either
right right and we will have director
buckon here um on the 31st so um he'll
be able to answer some questions um
representative
Belcher thank you madam chair thank you
for being here to answer these questions
for us I would like to ask some
questions about uh a topic that I'm not
actually sure you have all the answers
for us while I'll start with do you have
to put to put it bluntly in my
experience with federal funds there's
often sort of strings that come attached
to them things you need to do so do you
have information regarding what was
necessary for the state to do in receipt
and expending any of these particular
funds is that within your wheelhouse yes
so I with regard to the funds that
gopher was administering so again the
state local fiscal Recovery Fund under
arpa and then the Corona virus Relief
Fund funds under car act um there there
were no strings in terms of you must do
this in order to get the money that was
a straight almost entitlement payment
from the federal government to each of
the states I will say however that if
you wanted to try to find some strength
the the reporting that we have to do is
really substantive so I mean understood
of course that they want to be able to
account for that but that has taken a
lot of time and and will will in the
follow up yes can you can you go go a
little deeper into that as far as how um
how that that particular portion would
relate to the government um putting
requirements on any of the funding or
anything like that is that what you were
meaning well I guess I'm saying that uh
under arpa I would say in particular
there are specific expenditure
categories that we have to spend the
money and keep within there are uh and
so there's a large number of those C
categories and those categories have
their own requirements as to what is
eligible for that for that category and
what isn't so I
guess there were no strings to get the
money but I think that there has been
certainly a a lot of definition as to
how we're spending it based on the
expenditure categories I understand
thank
you representative
leus I am not I am not sure or what
monies came from
where you know who you would be
responsible for who others would but
this is a question from my
granddaughter who is having a hard time
hiring people as we're seeing all across
the state happens to be her current job
is is there still where do did the money
come from for the
extra um
unemployment and is that still in effect
in this state at all so I think what
you're referring to is at the at the end
of cares act when we got to uh the final
date that we had to have these funds um
obligated we used what we call waterfall
so the funds that were not um used at
that point all waterfall into the State
Unemployment Insurance Fund um in order
to um and I don't remember the exact
numbers Chase might remember but the
there were funds that went to that fund
that uh were aimed at reducing the
impact on employers uh so taking
basically their what would normally be
the requirement of the employers to fill
that fund and we use the cares act uh to
accomplish
that okay thank
you represent po off that was 109
way thank you Madame chair thank you for
being here uh I have a question so so
you testified that under arpa there
specific expenditure categories uh that
were recommended by as the understand
federal government so did State have
flexibility in
choosing
uh uh or denying certain
categories like if they say oh you have
spent on this category this category and
this category did New Hampshire have
flexibility to say oh we don't like this
specific category and we want be
spending on yeah so we don't have to
fill all the categories we would basic
what we have been doing is uh when we
are working with an agency or a
potential grantee of funds um we would
work with
to um make their program or their their
request um not necessarily fit but be
eligible for a particular criteria or
another but that was the extent of it
but we could choose we we don't have to
fill all the categories thank goodness
because there's a lot of
them
followup uh thank you uh and
uh more broadly um thank you for giving
us leg picture and uh showing how New
Hampshire was faster in allocating some
of those funds and thank you for your
work on after action report so we are
looking uh to read when it comes out but
can you give us right now some some
ideas uh we know that for example some
federal agencies like
cdcs uh like they look back and they
admitted some mistakes and they're
looking to do some improvements so I
wonder if uh in your
department uh you see something like
that areas that uh could be done better
next
time next Global
pandemic
um I would say I mean that's a tough
question I would have to think about
that but and I haven't had a lot of time
to reflect representative on questions
like that um but I I guess I could say
that um I felt that um we made some very
early decisions on what were going to be
some priorities and we ran really hard
at that I mean our staff um was
working easily you know 15 18 hours a
day uh in the middle of the pandemic um
you you'll remember this was a time when
you know the governor was having his
press conference every sing single day
and it was on and people were kind of
trying to figure out um working at home
and we know the state government was
kind of closed but kind of open and you
guys weren't here and it was um there
but there was a lot of activity that was
taking place by people to run at
specific issues that we felt were
priorities and um I think particularly
you know he has we haven't finished arpa
yet but the under cares Act I'm I'm
personally very proud of where of of how
we ended up I think we spent that money
very effectively I think that we uh gave
some um ability for the New Hampshire
economy to come out of um whatever we
call that now the uh covid experience in
a position of strength and I think the
data that we've seen since then does
reflect that um I think we certainly
learned a lot and this would be more of
a question for my colleagues at h
about um the public health component of
this I think obviously everybody learned
a lot uh about that um but speaking from
the economic side um I felt like uh we
made some pretty um good decisions uh
with those funds uh at the get-go time
will obviously tell but that's at least
now
followup uh thank you for this expl
explanation um I don't know if it's
something uh that uh you're comfortable
uh talking today if it's uh relevant but
you mentioned uh uh working closely with
uh uh Department of Health and Human
Services so I wonder if you can describe
us
uh uh how it works so you more on Mon
site and they making some additional
policy decisions uh so how that
interaction Jen
Leo so the interaction at the time you
had commissioner shanet uh at at
HHS um and her staff were obviously just
as engaged as gopher and my other
department ba um in uh the public health
side as we were on the economic side and
so a lot of the decisions again I would
say kind of in that early space of car's
act um there were a multitude of inputs
that were coming on almost every
decision um there was there's an
economic component there's a um human
rights component there's a healthc care
component um that were being made
certainly above my head you know in
terms of the final decisions but it was
a constant um discussion and dialogue
between those those uh um major issues
in making decisions about whether it's
funding or whether it was other things
that um HHS would have been more
responsible
for
followup thank you for that answer could
you clarify when when you say uh about
final
decision uh is it governor who is making
final decision is at some Council uh the
the governor during car's act again we
were under state of emergency at that
time so the governor was making almost
y um so yeah I'm looking at your website
um very well documented um the reports
are amazing um so I will just let you
know that so if anyone wants to see how
the money was spent especially under
car's they have uh reporting every month
through the end of May of
2022 you can also on um you can also
particularly on the cares act piece um
you can see on a is both on a map but
also um by program or by um by category
um the funds and you can also see who
received funds in each one of those
categories yeah I did see that you can
actually do it by address I believe so
um so great job there um I have a couple
questions um on the Main Street grant
part um actually I was uh instrumental
and for one company applying and the
other one filling out the paperwork to
make sure that we didn't have to pay it
back um and um based on the information
you receive back I
mean I noticed
personally in the business sphere that
we got a lot of um
people trying to collect unemployment
that never actually worked for a company
I mean I'm a small we're a small company
of less than 30 I was getting five to
six uh requests per week of people that
never work for the company um took a lot
of time um you know to reply back and
make sure we get everything reported
back um so knowing
that um based on what I was seeing just
on a small scale
um with some of these
programs um you know certain people were
following the rules and trying to do it
right did you see
fraud um in once the reporting was back
I know that you had to apply and you had
to fill out certain criteria to request
it but really the proof was in the
pudding when you had to send your
reports back to make sure that you
because that's when you really get to
see the final numbers I mean that's how
I would look at it but I could be wrong
um and I'm just wondering um if there
was any fraud or not so
um you know maybe people that I I don't
want to say fraud but didn't act in good
faith or whatever um would you put a
percentage on that at all um I think
that would be difficult but let me just
explain so first of all you mentioned
the unemployment program if you haven't
had a chance to talk with the New
Hampshire employment security about that
subject they would be good to talk to
because they were the ones that were
administering the extra unemployment
insurance F uh unemployment insurance
that we received as a state and trying
to navigate that process I I will say
from my standpoint there were certainly
a lot of people that needed those funds
and there were certainly a lot of people
who I think wouldn't have made it
without it
uh but to your point I think there might
have been some others that probably had
other um things in mind so that's you
know welcome to humanity but I think uh
as far as our programs go under Main
Street relief uh certainly there have
been I think some cases where we've had
inquiries um from law enforcement U some
of them are following up on um the PPP
program which you probably also recall
that was the Federal program um uh that
was run by the SBA and I know there were
some issues with that um that we did
have some uh some recipients under Main
Street that applied to both programs and
if they were being looked at by the feds
under the PPP program we would probably
get a similar inquiry to see if they
were had funds under Main Street but I
would say overall and I don't have a
percentage for you but overall the the
amount of New Hampshire companies that
were trying to commit fraud under that
program was really small um and and I I
guess I would add to that by saying that
the program itself what we did as you
will probably recall was we asked
businesses to try to anticipate what
their losses would be and we gave them a
percentage of their anticipated losses
for the year as a grant uh with the
understanding that if it was off by much
we were going to have to try to get some
of that money back because you didn't do
as poorly as you thought you did there
weren't I mean there were instances
where we had to uh undertake that but
with the exception of you know I don't
maybe a little more than a handful all
of those business said yep that was the
deal we we'll we'll pay you back and and
that worked and there was no I mean
there was some discussion about what the
amounts were and how that all worked but
it was pretty straightforward and again
um I would say that I was very
pleasantly surprised to see that at
least what we saw at that time was very
little abuse of of the program by New
Hampshire
employers that is really good news um
because I know out there in the
stratosphere you know we see it even now
on an uh dayto day that there are
nefarious characters trying to work
their way and swindle people all the
time so if I might just also make just
take a moment since we're Friday
afternoon anyway one other experience
that occurred during that time that I
like telling people is is that when we
first went into the covid um experience
again in April May of
2020 um we were in a at a level of some
desperation because I mean we remember
we were trying to get um medical
equipment PPE equipment we were trying
to figure out like what this was and uh
understand as best we could but also try
to you know uh lead from a from a state
standpoint
um one of the things that we did uh
again this was over in in my other job
at the business and economic Affairs
Department was we reached out to
manufacturers around the state and said
we need these things we need you know
medical equipment we need you know
gloves we need you know uh smoks and all
these other things and we had quite a
number of New Hampshire manufacturers
who changed their outputs and uh adapted
their equipment to meet that demand and
it was uh probably in my seven years in
in this position one of the most uh
encouraging uh moments of time when we
would see these businesses calling and
saying what can we do what can we make
to make uh make New Hampshire and the
people in New Hampshire safe and that
was um something i' like to share when I
have the opportunity because it speaks
to the New Hampshire business community
and that it is a I think a very unique
group of companies mostly small medium
siiz who when they see something that
they can help with they're willing to do
it and that was um something I'm very
proud of I remember that and thank you
for sharing and reminding us of that um
that was a really big deal at the time
and it was
amazing representative
eel I have to say at some level this
whole thing is giving a little bit of
PTSD oh me too representative I mean
just I'm slowly remembering things and
well talking about the those those phone
calls for go I can still hear the
clicking in my ears or they um well okay
I have a I have a couple questions one
mostly simple but this one so I mean
part of part of what we're working on is
again trying to understand how the
response flowed and I think you've
spoken really uh clearly about like how
manufacturers stepped up how everybody
was stepping up and I think there's a
lot of concern about rushing for
instance vaccines to Market or or you
know to the people
but I think your experience you can if
you want to expand on it to just talk a
little bit more about how it was almost
like a panic for all of us to get our
Public Health uh systems up to speed our
businesses up to speed um and you
know if there was a fault uh it was
maybe uh you know I think a lot of
people might feel like it was an
overreaction or some people feel like it
was an
overreaction but if you could talk a
little bit about the atmosphere you felt
at the state level to try to respond to
the needs of the state if you get what
I'm getting yes right and here comes the
PTSD again so no it was no and I don't
mean that and to be light about it
because it was very serious and very
um very difficult time I we
um we were physically located often at
the emergency Operation Center uh here
in conquer um we um were I would say in
the very early days there was a lot lot
of discussion a lot of states were
coming up with these essential business
lists and things they were going to
allow to be open or not open and this
sort of thing um we didn't really uh we
we had a lot of discussion about that
and and in the end I think that there
were some businesses that we felt
because we didn't know we were dealing
with we were going to have to
unfortunately put them in a position to
not be able to operate for a little
while and that was mostly restaurants uh
places uh where people had exposure to
each other
um uh and um I
think I have to say I'm not really that
familiar with how other states did it I
know some states around us um did it a
little differently than we did um we
made it a priority to lean toward
getting everybody back to an open
environment as quickly as we could
without endangering Public Health again
as we knew it at the time so uh the
reopening task force really was a great
tool for that because we were able to
have um public forums with business
owners or others Advocates interested
parties there were public meetings where
um you had a group of individuals from
the legislature you know from myself
included representatives of various
Industries um listen to and health and
human services and others from the from
state government listen to the concerns
of uh citizens and business owners and
others about you know should we what's
the what's going to be the deal with
movie theaters what's going to be the
story with u uh healthc care facilities
or bowling alleys I remember we had we
had like a whole two-hour meeting on
bowling alley so there was uh a constant
stream of input coming and those were
helpful because you had businesses said
yeah okay I get that this is the issue
but we can do these things so rather
than you just say you close us we can
separate people we can have spaces
between them we can have certain types
of cleansing protocols put in place and
that in some instances gave enough
confidence and I think over time gave
more confidence to our Public Health
teams to be willing to talk about you
know how can we manage them remaining
open and employing people without
endangering safety so there was a that
um did I answer that question I mean
yeah I I
guess it's hard now to look back and
fully appreciate what was going on at
that time
but would you be willing to say
that at the government level at which
you were operating everybody was trying
to do their level best to do the best
for the state and that perhaps mistakes
were made which is why we're here now
but everyone really was knocking
themselves out in good faith to do the
best they could no question about it
absolutely no question about it I mean
the team that we that I was working with
um took a a lot of personal toll I think
you know dealing with these types of
issues and taking them with the degree
of seriousness that that they deserved
um there is almost always going to be an
opportunity you know years later to look
at how that all turned out and and and
make some constructive criticism as to
how we could probably have done that
better here and there but the the pace
of the decisions that were being made
the environment that they were being
made within um the swirling public
health concerns and I mean frankly
Terror I mean we didn't know what we
were dealing with and what we were you
know what what this was going to evolve
into um I would say that one of the
things that I felt that we
really harped on was that once we all
agreed and the governor made a decision
we stuck to that decision and there
wasn't there wasn't a lot of um oh you
know let's change this or let's change
that and I and I think that volatility
in that type of environment is not good
and so keeping to a decision and sort of
pushing through um was a little bit of a
Hallmark I guess in our decision-making
process and maybe something for people
to think about and review and decide
whether or not that was you know the
best decision at the time I do believe
that it was and as from my standpoint um
from where we stand right now I I do
was there was a scramble I have compared
to that question I have some one that's
really easy do you have any idea how it
was determined how much money any
particular State got do you know how
that math worked probably population I
as I recall was per capita yeah so I'm
pretty sure that under cares act and
sfrf we got the minimum amount uh of
State based on our size kind of what I
thought right yeah and what was the
agency disseminating the funds okay go
so he just said that I think
particularly kak unemployment probably
also had something to do with it as well
but I do believe we received the minimum
amount in both of those programs and
were what were which agencies at the
federal level were disseminating the
money so uh it was Treasury Department
in both
cases thank you very much you're welcome
representative
leus yes this discussion is reminding me
of all the business owners that I spoke
to at the time and what a diverse set of
experiences they had there were ones who
were so appreciative of the money that
helped them keep afloat there were
others who um were
having such trouble getting all of the
applications Etc that they went bankrupt
before they actually got money and I was
just wondering if you would comment on
that because I remember it was very
varied okay that's a very good question
and and and and as you're saying that um
and thinking about some of the questions
that you've had previously an area we
could do better
right getting to all the
businesses is definitely won because we
leaned very heavily on uh trade groups
business you know like the the for the
restaurants we worked very closely with
lodging and Restaurant Association for
hotels um we were very closely with the
business and industry Association or
others the retail Federation others try
to get the word out there were
definitely businesses that were not
members of those organizations and maybe
didn't have time to read the newspaper
or watch
WMUR live 24-hour coverage of the
pandemic
um the uh getting in those types of inst
instances to a much broader set of
businesses and
potential uh recipients of relief is
something that we could have done better
on I and I think again those are
probably whether you want to have lists
or or that just we didn't have access to
at the at the pace we probably could
assembled them over time but um we were
not in a position to be able to reach
every single business the the Main
Street Relief Fund probably was better
than most because we used
Dr um uh addresses for most of that um
and so we we were getting taxpaying
businesses um alerted but um yeah
widescale
notification of available benefits to a
broad set of business owners and frankly
recipients is probably an area that we
could build a little bit more uh
resilient uh infrastructure around for
you on that would you say for
municipalities too I mean I wonder how
Municipal what was the sort of interface
with municipalities during this
time I I I mean a lot of municipalities
were put in a tough spot I mean because
they were here was a huge chunk of money
um that uh they were being asked to
deploy but they had no capacity to
really even um consider how they might
do something like that we at the again
back in KAC time we brought on a
consultant uh to work with gopher but we
also hired that consultant to provide
direct technical assistance to
municipalities um and that definitely
helped quite a
bit um in particular because when we got
by the time we got to
arpa um the state received that 994
million in sfrf funds every almost every
municipality in the state also received
funding directly from Treasury under the
sfrf fund so separate from the state's
allocation do you know how much that
was yeah I um I I can get that for you a
couple of months ago that would have
been the top of my head but I've
forgotten it by now but um it was a
pretty good amount and uh all
municipalities I think except one or
two uh accepted those funds and then all
10 counties also got sfrf
funds right because every County I'm
sure you got Opera funds in your account
but yeah yeah that's not included in the
994 that would be an interesting number
to yeah I would I would urge you to take
a look at that and how municipalities
managed there again I think we did what
we could to try to uh support the
municipalities um I will say that maybe
I might venture
that looks like number 112 million that
went to the uh is that for the
county okay so that was counties and
municipalities had access to $112
million separate from the 994 that the
state got was that a
direct well as I recall what they had to
do is they had to tell us they wanted it
and then and then then this the money
went directly from the federal
government so they're doing a lot you
all the things we've talked about end
expenditure categories and they're doing
the same thing uh yeah cuz in our County
we had a list of what we wanted to spend
our prop ER funds on so but what I was
going to say is that I I do I I I
suspect just because you know my
department works very closely with
municipal government on a lot of fronts
is as much of a as as as painful as that
experience has been in some cases for
for for
municipalities it has um raised issues
and questions locally that they've dealt
with how they would deal with locally
you know on their own sort of uh based
on their own values Etc
but has put them in a good good position
to also be willing to maybe think about
um how they are operating in a world
that is increasingly complex to get
whether it's Federal money or other
funds um it's put them in a stronger
position to to know how to access those
and to have maybe some resources to be
able to deal with them maybe with a
little bit of assistance whereas before
covid there were so many communities so
that was just not even not even
something that could have been
done um I'd like to go back to something
you had spoken about earlier with the
reopening of different businesses and
things like that and um obviously you
dealt more with the monetary side would
you say that the decisions to reopen
besides the would come down to HHS
mostly
um making that ultimate decision
I think in most cases um HHS was very
much part of the discussion and the and
the meetings and the hearings and
everything they were full partner and
all of that and so but when we got to
the point of saying you know these are
these are going to be the final
recommendations they were very much part
of that discussion as they as they
needed to be um you know and and so
there was a definite Public Health uh
consideration to every one of those
decisions only because and I my memory
could be wrong
but yeah I remember this um but I
believe you know when we shut down
restaurants and bars and everything else
we let
private clubs open prior to the public
restaurants and I'm not I don't know if
memory is serving me correctly but it
seemed that way um and I was just
wondering how that you know it's kind of
like uh restaurants got open but Church
you you know there was there's a lot of
yeah you know I'm I'm sure there was a
lot must have been crazy on on how to
make those decisions yeah um yeah and I
don't remember that distinction uh but
it might have been
um but yeah those look I'm the
commissioner of business and economic
Affairs the last thing I wanted to do is
close the business it's like I didn't
sign up for that so um so it was it was
make and
did you how do I how do I put this um
with the roll out of the unemployment
funds and people getting to collect
those excess
dollars from
unemployment when they could go back to
work um from an employee standpoint we
found that some would rather that it
actually hurt
businesses and
had a negative
that
um I think that there were probably some
instances where you could say that
um the the way that some people reacted
to that didn't it put us a little bit
deeper in the workforce
Hole uh and um I'm not sure
and I haven't looked at the data enough
to be able to say if there's like a
correlation between the increased
benefits and the workforce but I think
that there were there was definitely a
lot of real world experience that kind
case yeah and well personal experience
um and I can speak to a couple of
different instances where uh somebody I
knew worked as a
Ender but yet the when it reopened the
people that were there said why should I
bother um so in some instances in the
service industry I think it really hurt
no question um and so the service
industry and hospitality industry got
got banged up worse than anybody I think
and and and it and it is a little bit of
what maybe you're describing but it's
also I think there were and talking with
a lot of business owners in that space
as well there were a lot of people are
like you know I'm going to go do
something else I'm going to go get you
know spend a couple months at the
community college on an advanced
manufacturing program and I'm going to
do the second shift to you know mport
Sigma or something so uh that definitely
occurred there was a uh literal you know
earthquake in the labor markets as a
result of covid and people re thought
being in the workforce people rethought
about what they were doing in the
workforce the remote work issue really
started to come into play so it really
fundamentally changed the landscape that
we operated under until that point I'm
not sure that it's all shaken out even
to this point right uh I I will say that
I've had a number of meetings and we
have a we have a big meeting next week
with the tourism
industry for the first time since Co I'm
getting a little bit of feedback that
they're finding the workforce they need
in the hospitality space come for this
coming summer which is encouraging uh I
Pro I can't possibly say that that's
100% but it is it is coming back around
but how it came back around and how it's
different from before still jury is
that thank you for that and
difference and you know we had honest
people that actually came back to work
even though um with those excess federal
dollars they probably would have made
more staying home but they were bored um
so lucky us uh for that um but uh it
definitely uh changed uh the landscape
uh of the workforce and I I think in
some way it did hinder I actually had a
gentleman come in and say you need to
sign me back up for this and I need to
be collecting this and I'm like yeah
no I mean almost I mean it was crazy but
tough times um so yeah so that's what we
got to see uh represent B I'm actually
saying that what you did about referring
to remote
um could you talk a little bit about the
uh Broadband lift that New Hampshire got
as a result of Co I I it just seems to
me that we're way ahead of where we were
in that yes so that's a good point too
uh uh representative so um in addition
there uh has been a total I'm it's like
$250 million of funding through both
car's act and um arpa and now separately
from another program called bead um that
the state has received that my
department not gopher but baa is
deploying uh to really get us to 100%
access to high-speed internet for people
who want it um we are well underway with
those programs so we did we have two
companies right now that are um putting
in fiber all over rural New Hampshire uh
this summer and started they started
last summer but the time that process is
over we do expect to have a minimum of
50,000 new addresses with access to um
highspeed fiber uh uh highspeed internet
so that does a lot of things it
obviously helps people that work
remotely it also helps families whose
kids are assigned work that they have to
do on computer it's it helps you know
older people who can't get to see their
doctor to be able to have a video
conference you know all the things we
sort of do on a regular basis uh in the
business World these days just about a
lot more accessible um the other thing
that it does is it levels the playing
field for a lot of communities where um
you've had for years situations um in
rural New Hampshire where you have one
town that might have um access to fiber
and highspeed internet another that next
door that does not guess what the
property values are like in those two
towns right so um leveling that playing
field giving uh a new uh important
foundation to the Future uh trajectory
of the New Hampshire economy it's pretty
exciting stuff so uh I I I have said and
I'm happy to say it again that by the
time we're done with these resources we
will have 100% access uh to people that
want in for high-speed internet in New
Hampshire which for individuals uh who
have been working on this for the last
10 or 15 years and struggling to get
peanuts from the federal government to
assist with broadband expans
this is a truly a once in a-lifetime
opportunity to get this taken care of
and and do you know what do you have a
kind of a completion date in mind so for
the two uh for so we have two contracts
one with New Hampshire Electric
Cooperative and one with Consolidated
Communications those two have to be
complete by the end of 2026 but both are
telling me right now that they will be
done in
2025 and so again speaking to our
experience versus other states we will
be the first state in the Northeast
maybe even on the east coast to reach
that 100% number uh than any other state
uh because a lot of other states have
been going about this quite differently
um not better not worse better in my
view but you know that's a debate for
some for others to have but um we will
be able to offer that to our citizens
sooner than anyone
else so
wow that's amazing so by the end of this
year we'll be 100% end of 2025 oh 2025
don't skip ahead representative 2024
well I'm skipping ahead all this talk
about
Co represent PO is off uh thank you so
so you had some questions about uh
whether paying L unemployment benefits
uh for incentivizing people from looking
uh employment when they could so in
similar line of thinking if we were
paying businesses for their expected
losses and then we were telling them if
you will overcome it and be more
successful you you have to pay us back
so in my view it it
also probably incentivized some
businesses not to work as hard as as
they good so what's your
SS I don't know too many businesses that
are looking to reduce their profit to
avoid having to pay back a grant um but
um I suppose that might might have been
the case here or there but you know most
businesses and there were some that that
that did not uh have as as good a year
as they had anticipated and so they were
able to hold on to those funds and use
them however they saw fit but by the
same token they were plenty of
businesses and on my sense is that most
of them were happy to have not had the
year that they had anticipated so they
they were uh our our repayment rate was
quite
High um I know you didn't have anything
to do with the PPP loans but uh with the
SBA but Main Street
grant program was really good um it
wasn't a ton of money um but they made
it as simple as possible uh for
businesses to apply and to report back
little bit strenuous um but not as bad
as the other reports that are
required um the one thing I would note
when dealing with any of these
is a lot of them were based on sales not
necessarily the Main Street Grant but
they were based on sales and during that
time everyone had to raise their
prices just to cover the increase in
costs of goods so your sales number
actually increased more than what you
would have thought it would be although
your losses were
greater um and I think and I'm not I
can't remember cuz you know all the
numbers are jumbled together but that
was one of the things I found very
disconcerting is they um based it on
sales numbers and not actually sales you
know gross profit because of that
increase in uh cost of goods um that I
think every business was experiencing
and there was no way you could even
capture those costs because you would be
out of business uh cuz you people would
not buy the product um what are your
thoughts on that
um in in the future just well I mean
again going back in time I think we
were and the federal government uh
probably I had nothing to do with that
think basic it on sales and as you're
saying the increase of those costs that
that came after right so I think the
decision to at least ours in terms of uh
anticipated Revenue was was solid
because we were we were kind of still
living in 2019 right so the the increase
in cost of goods came from supply chain
disruptions that occurred um once the
pandemic took hold and then those we're
still recovering from that
frankly right so like I said uh the Main
Street Grant much simpler uh might much
straightforward in in my view to fill
out um but if we were to do something
like that again I think um one of the
things we would look at or should look
at is if there are increased cost to go
along with those numbers um well that in
the mechanism too I mean we went
directly to the businesses whereas PPP
went through banks primarily right so
um and I think you I mean you talked to
a lot of businesses that PPP saved them
probably just as much if not more than
Main Street but um that was an important
part of the puzzle but um exactly what
the mechanism should be in that type of
an emergency situation what's the most
effective way to get relief to a
business and to as many businesses as we
can um are are probably questions that
we should be taking some time to
consider because you know who knows
hopefully
never any of us around but you know
maybe maybe future versions of us will
watch this video and have couple of
couple of Clues so what they could try
to
do at least now we have a little bit
more of a road map than we did before
for yeah I mean well you could take this
and apply it to a lot of different types
of instances right it doesn't have to be
a global pandemic right and and we're
we're our report is not only to look to
see what we could what we got right too
right so what did we do right not just
what we did wrong so um that's really
important too so that if anyone looks at
it they understand you know our approach
versus other approaches like you said
the Main Street Grant anch you were able
to because you use Dr so you were able
to get that out to businesses where some
of the other stuff if they weren't you
didn't belong to an association you
probably weren't really familiar yeah or
or was it the PPP loan that did the deer
I can't remember yeah they're all yeah
do we know how much money the PPP
program
provided I'm going really fast um I
don't know off the top of my head but
I'm sure that's data EAS
easily found yeah um well we probably
should let you go but I was just going
to say from the talking about the
Broadband I mean and health bringing us
back to us from a tella Health
standpoint Behavioral Health mental
health I'm sure uh getting people access
to broadband must have been tremendously
helpful yes yes and it continues to be
yeah I mean it got us going right and
one of the positives that came out of it
is that teleah Health medicine right so
um that is that is really a positive I
think and it gives people better access
uh to good medicine are there any other
questions thank you so much commissioner
for being here this been a pleasure I
truly appreciate your time thank you so
much and thank you for doing this this
is an important part of the equation
it's U it's a lot to take in I'm sure um
but I'm happily happy to travel down the
PTSD road with you uh anytime it's been
an interesting Journey this afternoon
and if you could get those numbers to us
yes I'll get you those numbers and if
you think of anything else in the
interum be sure to just shoot me an
email we'll try we can get you what you
need okay thank you all right thank you
um I'd like to adjourn the meeting and
uh our next meeting will be May 31st